all right so back to science and the and
the topic
for today so i'm going to begin with a
conversation with cameron vapha and then
i'll segue into
your questions we'll take your questions
during that session as well
cameron vaffa is the hollis professor of
mathematics and natural philosophy at
harvard university he has won
so many awards that it would take half
of our time to list them all the
breakthrough prize is certainly
one of those he's well known for
tremendous
ideas that have set the course of
many areas of research into string
theory
again we'll talk about some of them but
perhaps those of you who've read my
books
are familiar with the work that he did
with andrew strominger
giving us the first microphysical
calculation of the
entropy of a certain class of black
holes which is rightly regarded
as one of the real crowning achievements
of
string theory so let me bring in now my
friend
professor kumar baffa so welcome cameron
nice to see you ryan good to see you
thanks for for joining us
i know you're from home at the moment i
think
yeah and um and and just uh just to
sort of get into things so i i your
professor at harvard
and harvard just recently announced as
many places are that it's going fully
online with its education have you done
online perhaps in the spring
did you do online teaching of your
students sabbatical leave on spring
prevented me from teaching
so i'm having the experience that i have
given lectures by zoom but not the
class it was it would be an interesting
experience beginning this fall
yeah you know most people in fact this
even came up at a meeting at harvard
because you know that i'm on
on one of the overseers committees there
that there's a general sense that
teaching
via zoom or online is always
a pale reflection a poor approximation
to the experience in the classroom but i
was sort of the lone voice in that
meeting and i said
i kind of feel like the teaching
can be just as good it's different than
engaging
one-on-one but you know in in in small
ways and large i'll give you one small
thing i don't know about you
but i never can remember all my students
names i really wish
i could but i can't but in zoom all
their names are like right
there so i can like call on jim or call
on mary and
it actually adds a personal touch that
like i can't do in the live class
because i can't i can't actually
remember
that's sort of a minor thing account
yeah
yeah exactly uh but uh but yeah i think
it will be a
i'd be interested to talk to you after
you know some of your sessions to see
you know how you're thinking about
things i also want to um just announce
to folks that
you've got a new book out
well that's the wrong side of it there
we go over here beautiful new book
puzzles to unravel the universe and
i was fortunate to receive uh a nice
advanced copy
from you and uh enjoyed reading it
tremendously so just to sort of get into
things
what what you know it's a question that
many authors are asked
every book interview that i've had often
they ask you know
what is it that drove you to write this
book so let me just start in in that way
at all what was your motivation
well um part of the motivation was to
try to communicate
with the public about the things that
excites me about science
and i thought that maybe maybe there's a
room for hands-on kind of
relation between the public and the
science and i thought puzzles is a way
that that could
uh it's a good vehicle to try to bring
this connection a bit more
hands-on experience instead of just
reading they will get to do something
and feel what is going on really
and in fact it's based on a course that
i've been teaching
actually originally suggested by my wife
offering to originate this course to
to kind of communicate with uh with
freshmen uh
at harvard uh this quote called this
course called physics puzzles and math
and based on this special seminar which
has been going on for about 10 years now
i gradually develop more and more
puzzles and tools to kind of communicate
with with people who are not necessarily
going to be physicists but they're
interested in learning about
how the physics goes about and how what
are the basic ideas and i thought puzzle
is a fun way
to get them into into seeing what are
these deep ideas and
you know the puzzles don't have to be
complicated to kind of illustrate some
of the points and
uh the nice thing is that even simple
puzzles can relate to
you know the latest things we are doing
in physics modern physics you know what
are the
uh latest and intermost interesting
aspects of the fundamental physics can
be
connected to simple looking math puzzles
and this was both a fun way as well as
educational way to bring this about and
that was
uh through this experience from this
course i decided that it would be great
to have this
in the form of a book that others can
also uh benefit
even those who are not possibly the
students in my class
were you uh were you a a puzzle-solving
kid i mean is that something that
fired you up when you were young yes i
loved puzzles i
always loved puzzles and i always tried
to
you know it was always fun thinking
about them but i also had this view
about
things around me which later got me
interested in science
which also was a way like viewing the
whole thing as a big puzzle
and uh you know to me to me from the
childhood kind of questions like you
know
why is this thing moon up there and it's
not falling
and why is this and that in this way and
that way so these kind of things that
are around us even as childhood kind of
got me started thinking and and then
puzzles was kind of
a more simpler and more
uh well-structured way of asking
a simple question and it was much
simpler than the complexity of the
reality around us
but it was a way to kind of get me
started in thinking about things that i
found amazing about our universe and
this and that later on but uh
well it started from my interests as
shown in each as child
now sometimes when people hear the word
puzzle they think
in terms of you know it's fun it's it's
it's a game sometimes when we think
about
the questions of the universe we use
very different language that has
a more sort of gravitas more profound
quality to it do you find with your
students that
there's any tension between those
different sort of levels of profundity
you know the gamification versus sort of
the
profound investigations into the nature
of the world or do they
seamlessly come together they actually
seamlessly come together i would say
because
even even i would even as physicists
even when we do research and you well
know this
of course brian that when we see
something is
is gets gets understood it is always in
simple terms
if something is complicated we don't
feel we haven't understood it so
it should eventually be the profound
ideas should be so simple that
quote unquote the kids should also be
able to understand otherwise we don't
think we have understood it
so this simplification or understanding
in simple terms is a requirement
requirement really to say we really
understood something and
it's not like if you have something
which is profound it should look complex
in fact it's the opposite if it is
complex means you really haven't quite
understood it you have to bring it down
to spare bone to simple terms and only
then can you
really feel you have understood it so
most puzzles that we get set
by you know in school or or even in your
book
they're made up by a human being
when we are investigating the sort of
the puzzles of nature
do you feel that that is ultimately
a holy human quest that we kind of look
out at the world and
we puzzle about things and we frame our
questions perhaps in a mathematical
language but ultimately as you say it's
just a puzzle
or is there com some kind of deeper
source
for these puzzles it's a good question i
have thought quite a bit about the
relation of puzzles
magic and the universe and how this
works to me
universe has this magical quality and
like puzzles which are sometimes magical
and
we try using scientific methods to try
to explain this magic
and there's a difference between the the
the regular magics and the universe as a
magic
scientific explanation of it does not
make it less magical
in fact it adds to its spell so it's
kind of a little different from regular
puzzles so it's not something like we
made it up
it's kind of uh it's kind of there and
we we
try to understand it we don't know with
our own terms
it has a different quality of a puzzle
it's a different quality of magic to it
than
than regular things that are that we can
make of course we get inspired by things
around us and we
make we try to parallel what we see
around us in the universe but i would
say that
it's not like something we have imposed
uh from us to the universe but rather we
are just
we're just mirroring what we see in some
form
in some obviously imperfect way in our
way
to try to model it in some form right we
thought it would be fun
since it's a book on puzzles uh you know
in a moment we'll turn to
questions of string theory and space and
time but we thought it'd be kind of fun
during that conversation
if there's some folks out there that
want to puzzle over a puzzle
and see if they can come to the solution
so if you compose one of your puzzles
and our thought was
for those of you who are out there that
are interested to try to solve it
the solution should take the form of a
picture that shows the solution to the
puzzle
and in the chat world science fest will
post
i believe it's an email address or some
other place you can see it
where you can post your solution and
among those who get the right answer
we'll do like a little random draw and
you'll get a
a signed copy of kermit vapha's new
book as a prize that the festival will
provide to you so
give us one puzzle that that you think
fits into this category of
interesting things for people to ponder
sure
um well one puzzle is the following
take consider four cities i gave them
name a
b and c and d and the four corners of a
square
so they are equally this i mean the
neighbor ones are equally distant a and
b and a and c are the same distance and
they form corners of a square
and the task is to find the highway
system which connects all these cities
now the highway system
that you find should have the shortest
total length
it should be able to connect every city
to every other city
it does not have to be a direct
connection between every city and every
other city as long as you can go from
any city to any other city
that is fine and we just want to know
what is the shortest highway system that
connects all these cities of course
shortest highway system is useful
because you want to have you want to
spend least amount of money if you want
to connect old cities
and so that's the puzzle and what it has
to do with physics and so forth perhaps
we can explain afterwards so the form of
the solution will be
someone's got to write down draw a
highway system connecting the four
cities take a picture of it
send it in and really specify the
details
of the directions that those various
roads are taking
and exactly exactly no no no need for
proof of it just
yeah just the explain just the drawing
and then the
specification on the drawing sufficient
all right so if anyone's still paying
attention to our conversation as opposed
to trying to solve the puzzle
uh we're gonna we're gonna move on from
there we'll come back to the solution uh
toward the end of discussion
so so your line of research you know in
mine
as well for a long time has been in the
area of unified theories
string theory of course as many people
who are
listening to us well know einstein
himself
was in search of a unified theory toward
his final
days on planet earth and and never
really found it for you what's the
motivation
what's what's the drive to find this
this sort of final theory or this this
unified theory
well i uh i think that
i enjoy it without understanding why i
enjoy it
and uh i don't think it's an aim to find
the final theory because i don't think i
would
i will for sure not be able to succeed
i'm sure about that
i don't think uh it would be something
achievable in our lifetimes
so it's not it's not a it's not a
precise goal
as as a final quest or something for me
i think it's a kind of a journey more
than anything
and uh i feel that the thing that
amazes me is that discovering something
beyond us this discovering
and connecting something bigger than
ourselves discovering that
there's something out there which is
resonates in us
and we can kind of understand pieces of
it and make sense out of it
which is longer than our short lifetimes
and
what and much much bigger in space and
validity than the tiny
place like earth that we live in it's
it's applicable to the whole universe
understanding these laws allows us to
feel a little more connected to the
meaning of the whole
existence in a broader term that is
really what i want that's what gives me
satisfaction
yeah when i try to connect things and
try to see the connections
it's like seeing a piece of art or
enjoying it and just
even if even if i'm not doing it and if
somebody else is doing it and just
watching it
it's already inspiring and and it makes
me really
uh enjoy it and so that is also another
aspect so it's just
beauty of it beauty of appreciation of
what's going on is another aspect so
of course being part of it and doing
minor contributions here and there makes
it even more fun
sure so you know i've asked and answered
the following question like 10 000 times
over the course of uh
the last decade or so so i'm happy to
seed it over
to you can you give us a just for those
who perhaps don't know what's the basic
idea of string theory
i've always wanted to ask that question
i've always answered it i've never asked
it before
you are the expert on it beautifully i
cannot do any any better than you for
sure brian but
uh i don't know what is the easy way to
say what string theory is
uh i would say that uh well i was i
would start perhaps by
by describing a little bit uh about what
what
what is the basic questions before i get
to what string theory is of course
uh you know from old days we know uh we
know gravity
uh from newton's day he understood the
quantitative understanding of how
gravity works and later we learned about
uh you know particles uh fundamental
particles things like electrons
and uh when when when we understood
electrons and how the atomic structure
works we found quantum mechanics is
crucial this was last century
beginning of that century and so when
people tried to put together
newton's theory which was beautifully
extended by geometrical idea of einstein
when he wanted to combine that piece of
physics with quantum mechanics which
described the tiny pieces of atoms it
didn't work and
it came accidentally it was actually
discovered by physicists
trying to do something completely
unrelated that if you start talking
about the vibrating tiny objects instead
of point particles
instead of points like tiny littles like
spaghetti loops but very very tiny
then you somehow manage to get rid of
these contradictions that
einstein theory had with quantum
mechanics which describe how electrons
work
so this was the emergence of the idea of
string theory basically as a way
to resolve the paradoxes between
einstein's theory
and quantum mechanics so the the
einstein theory which is great in
describing how things work at large
distances
and quantum mechanics which was great
with short distances got unified
using this this extra ingredient that
fundamental objects are not points
not point particles but extended little
loops
and these vibrations of these loops give
rise to different kinds of particles and
different kinds of interactions
emerge from from strings let me just
jump in right there though i want to ask
you a question on that freeman dyson
in an article that i read in the new
york review of books but i think he's
had said it in different locations as
well
he questioned whether we should ever
even
worry about the contradictions between
general relativity and quantum mechanics
he said there's there's there's no
reason to worry about that they're just
describing distinct realms of reality
and the contradictions are arising
because you don't want those realms to
be described
in the same language does that hold any
water for you
well i'm i'm not sure exactly what what
you might refer to because we already
know that
there are many pieces of science which
emerge from contradictions
in some sense we welcome contradictions
because contradictions point
towards something we don't understand
and potential resolution of that leads
to new ideas
however there is one sense in which i
can i can perhaps understand what he may
have meant
and that is in the context of what we
call duality and string theory
so occasionally we come up with two
completely different pictures which look
contradictory contradictionary
contradicting each other in some way
but this contradiction gets resolved
by viewing it in a very novel way so
it's kind of like a different viewpoint
so you have two different things which
look like there's some inconsistency but
there is not
of course trying to figure out why it's
not is the key
it is the key to understanding what is
going on so
the apparent contradictions are there
but not a real contradiction and i think
maybe that's what he's referring to
so we shouldn't be bothered by apparent
contradictions but we should perhaps
welcome them as a
opportunity to get to understanding
deeper
reality behind why they are the same or
why there are no conditions at all
yeah no certainly i mean you think about
special relativity emerging
the contradictions between
electromagnetic theory and newtonian
mechanics
you can think about quantum mechanics
emerging as a contradiction between
observational data of certain particular
systems and the classical description of
those systems
so i i totally agree that contradictions
have been
the most fruitful things that we
physicists have encountered i think what
freeman dyson was referring to
he he didn't believe that gravitons
exist he didn't think that gravity would
ever need to be
quantized um i i'm not exactly sure
how he justified that thinking because i
mean we'll talk about in a minute but
when you think about things like black
holes
or the big bang it seems quite clear
that to gain the full understanding you
need to put
general relativity together with quantum
mechanics because it's
extreme realms of gravity and tiny
realms of space and it's very hard to
imagine a description that wouldn't
unite them but i guess
he was thinking that we would one day
just have distinct descriptions that
would never require gravity and quantum
mechanics to talk to each other
again it's hard for me to understand
where he justified that thinking and uh
i gather it's it's hard for you to see
it as well yes i think
i i think that the quest we have in
science is unification of ideas
to us having different realms which have
nothing to do with each other and
describe reality is not
is not it's not a happy ending for
understanding what is the
ultimate goal of what is the how do the
things relate it's kind of giving up
yeah i don't think i will i'll subscribe
with that to that viewpoint but
uh but of course we have understood much
more i think
especially in recent times but
connections usually you mentioned black
holes
uh and for example fundamental things
that we mentioned electrons
you might think what does an electron
fundamental anti this tiny thing
have to do this massive singularity and
space we should have a picture of like a
little black hole how could they have
anything to do with each other and now
we have learned via string theory that
they are related
and the simplest relation to explain is
that
we have learned the following fact is
from string theory that
gravity is always no matter what kind of
imagine
universe you might imagine is always the
weakest force so
for example the electron has attract has
a repo
if you have two electrons they have
repulsion electric repulsion force
which is much stronger than their
gravitational attraction by a factor of
10 to the power of 40 or something
so it's a huge difference between these
forces gravity is always the weakest
force the electrons really strongly
repel
compared to the tiny attractive force
they feel and the question is why
and we learned that this has to do with
the properties of black holes
so understanding black hole that thing
which has nothing to do a priori with
this tiny little electron
gets to explain the fact that they're
always
gravity is always the weakest force so
these kind of connections
come from quantum aspects of gravity and
gravitons existing and all that
which are crucial in hanging the whole
thing together so these elementary
excitations like electrons or gravitons
and these big excitations like big black
hole are actually
intimately deeply related and we have
seen exactly many examples of that by
now
in strength yeah in a number of uh
of the chat comments i'm just quickly
looking at them
by a number of the listeners like uh
raju radi
and one listener whose name
indicates the question at hand their
name is loop quantum gravity
so a natural question is so string
theory is an approach to putting
general activity in quantum mechanics
together there other approaches that
have been
put forward what do you think about loop
quantum gravity
i think no approach is on par with with
the amount we understand in string
theory so i think it's
fair to say that the the the other
approaches are attempts and many of them
uh there are not too many attempts but
none of them are
as has developed as in context of string
theory and perhaps there's some
connections and we may discover between
some
some pieces of these ideas within string
theory but i would say that they are not
on par with strength here
right yeah i uh i hold a similar view
but i think we're both
perhaps biased the other the other
community might
might have said the same thing in
reverse but uh let them have their own
discussion if they want to uh
exactly exactly so you know one of when
i
was um a graduate student back in the
80s which is more or less the time
when you were when did you get your your
your degree 85 19
i got my 86 yeah so around the same time
you know there was a general sense
that we both can recall that
some people were saying okay the end of
physics
is near right we have this new theory
it's just going to
unify gravity and quantum mechanics
together give us the final description
of everything
and at that time the older physicists
i think knew well that this was over
exuberance
that i remember i remember talking to ed
whitton at the time
uh and you know he was like this is
extremely exciting but
he was like you know slow it down a
little bit in
in your expectation for where this is
going to go
now we are say 35 years
later what's your view in terms of how
far
string theory has gotten i mean if you
were to grade
string theory what what grade would you
give it
well string theory is like opening a
room which is totally dark
and beginning to shine light on pieces
of it and you don't know how deep
or how complicated what shapes you're
gonna find
so i can easily see that with 35 years
ago or so we we might have thought you
know the room is tiny you know one
flashlight the whole thing is done we
get the
all aspects ready and understood and
ready to go
but of course if you have a you don't
know if it's a tiny room or it might be
actually a big tunnel or it could be
completely complicated so
so i think it's hard to give it a grade
because uh because it's
uh we don't still know what is the
totality of this
this thing that we are calling string
theory we have it's like really walking
and you know
shedding light on this piece and that
piece and saying oh no no this is not
just a you know a little room it's
actually a big cave or this big this and
that's so we're beginning to
get pieces of it understood and so it's
going to take a while for us
to really delve into all aspects of
string theory what i would say is that
we have discovered so many
little corners in that room that are so
exciting each little thing
each little thing is like a gem and we
have you know we said wow look at this
little thing here isn't it cool
let's try to understand what it means
about the rest of physics and we got
we get absorbed this for a few years i
said oh no no no there's this other gem
over there and so forth so
it's like a kid walking around in this
little that is a candy store and
discovering this and that and so forth
and
putting all together and you might ask
okay so are you done with this candy
store no no we're still
continuing our journey in this in this
uh in this way and
what grade i can give i would say we
have found so many exciting stuff
in string theory that it's it's it's you
could give a grade of a
plus but if you ask have you been able
to
connect to any single experimental
result that you can actually explain
using your theory
the grade is not not a for sure we have
not been able to do that so therefore
depends on what is the exact aim and we
can we can only be modest in that we can
do
continue this journey understand pieces
of it we have connected many different
aspects of physics together we have
understood
how quantum theory and uh gravity can be
consistent we have
seen how gravity is could be related to
a manifestation of
forces like electromagnetic forces or
generalizations of it
we have seen how dualities work
something which is
looks one way could be completely
related to completely different things
so these kind of
different aspects have shed huge light
about what we understand we have learned
so much more about black holes we have
learned
many many things and of course the
longer this journey is perhaps the more
we're going to
learn more new exciting things so
therefore maybe we shouldn't
aim to have a short journey so longer
journey may not be so bad
but of course it would be nice to get a
few experiments on the way as we
walk on this journey well some some
string theorists
have said i wonder what your view is
they
point to the developments that began in
the
late 1990s that showed a very deep and
unexpected
link between string theory and the more
traditional way that
physics has been able to describe
elementary particles namely quantum
field theory
and the deep connection between string
theory and quantum field through some
string theorists that i've spoken to
take the position that the experimental
program of testing string theory needs
to be seen in a different light
they would say hey once you find this
deep connection between strength here
and quantum field three well quantum
field theory you already know that
certain quantum field theories
are spectacularly good at describing
real world physics
and once you have the link between
string theory and quantum field theory
then in some sense the experimental
program isn't
as crucial as you perhaps once thought
it was
what's your view of that i would not i
would not agree with that first of all
we would need to have to just to say
that
some kind of gravity theory is
consistent with our
understanding of string theory and
therefore let's let's not worry about
the details of our universe
that's basically not giving up on
interesting things that could be related
to
the universe we live in or universes
that could be possibly
uh consistent and perhaps even reachable
from our universe so i would say that uh
saying that something is consistent less
than not dealt any further
is basically again giving up so i would
say that to say that
gravity might be related to other forces
is of course great strength
unifies them but we would like to know
more we would like to understand
what aspects of our universe is is
related
to the consistency of gravity with these
other forces
can we make further predictions are
there other kind of particles that they
should be there
can we learn anything about dark matter
can we learn anything about dark energy
from
from the string theory perspective we
know that there's this uh
non-vanishing energy permitting the
whole space what does it have to do with
einstein's theory of gravity what does
it have to do with the fundamental
forces are there any relations between
them
can we make a prediction about the fate
of the universe all these exciting
questions that we need to understand and
i think
they're extremely exciting to understand
for our universe and understanding
what predictions we have about the
universe that we live in rather than
some some hypothetical possible universe
that we don't even know
whether it's relevant for our universe
so understanding more specific things
about our universe
is is something that we still lack in in
our in our understanding of strength
theory
so do you consider string theory to say
to be falsifiable
string theory is falsifiable in many
ways but to make it
very falsifiable you have to have a very
specific
universe in mind so for example i would
say that if you
just would be an aspect of
falsifiability suppose
you have you have an accelerator which
can produce
energies which are 10 to the power of 20
let's say higher than the energy of a
proton
suppose you go to that high end energy
which is if you can
arrange such a huge amount of energy
then uh
if you don't see any evidence for
extended objects of one form or another
i would say that
that falsifies the theory so so there is
a prediction that you have to be able to
see something coming up there
of course that's very far from the realm
of experience we can do today
by many many orders of magnitude and
energy our or
our even the large hadron collider is
is a very tiny energy compared to the
energy we need to reach to
falsify string theory so falsifiability
of the string theory is
at this technologically we are not at
the point where we can actually do it
now
but here it but i mean at least
theoretically we could
see it falsified of course otherwise it
won't be a piece of science sure
you know when i look back on the papers
that i've written in my career i'd say
that i don't know
90 of them rely on something called
super symmetry
in one way or another and
many of us who have the same perspective
as you that in principle you can test
strength
if you have a big enough accelerator you
can actually in principle
try to detect the extended nature of a
string and as you say if you don't
see it then that would be pretty good
evidence against it if you do see it
that'd be pretty good evidence for it
but of course we don't have those
machines
we have to deal with what we have and
many of us thought that supersymmetry
this quality of nature that for every
known particle there'd be a partner
particle many of us almost took it as a
foregone conclusion
that the large hadron collider would
discover these
super partner particles and that way
confirm supersymmetry
it didn't happen or at least it hasn't
happened
was that did you find that disappointing
what's your reaction but i wouldn't say
that we were predicting it necessarily i
mean
so let me let me say that so just like
you i
actually was hoping that we would see
some evidence for supersymmetry in the
large hadron collider
but evidence was against it in the sense
that the amount of things that we
we saw from other experiments did not
point
towards being able to see supersymmetry
in string theory we believe
supersymmetry this this amazing symmetry
between different kinds of
particles bosons versus fermions should
be true
at some energy scale in string theory
that energy scale
has to be something that is uh
is measurable in some sense but may not
be
at the low energy that we can probe in
the large hadron collider
it could be all the way up to the
energies which we call the planck energy
this huge energy that
is the ultimate energy that we can reach
so it could be that you need to get
so high in energy to see the evidence
for supersymmetry
we were hoping you know who knows maybe
we are lucky and you know that you could
see it at low energy and then we'll be
happy
we didn't see it but i wouldn't say that
that dismayed me in terms of
believing in string theory let's say or
to say that it had to be seen no
we were just hoping that if we if it is
there then maybe we can get more insight
into the inner workings of string theory
and how it connects to our universe
so it's disappointment in that sense i
wouldn't say it's a theoretical
disappointment it's just like
circumstantial disappointment of the
universe we live in which does not have
supersymmetry realize that social low
energy of course it's not still over
they could you know it's the large
hadron collider experiment is still
going on and
you know they could have some evidences
for that but it's getting i would say as
you say less likely
and and i wouldn't bet on it as as i
would say
it's less likely even than before the
experiment but
i would say that that does not change my
view about string theory
so turning away from say the
experimental side of things which
you know as we've indicated is
less successful but not necessarily a
black mark
against strength they're in turning
towards some of the great successes
so your own work on on black holes an
enormous success
more recently there's also been a
tremendous amount of activity
trying to understand the true nature of
space and time in a quantum mechanical
theory of gravity within string theory
have you been impressed by those
developments any any thoughts on where
you
think the promising avenues of research
are in trying to understand a question
like that
well there are aspects of trying to
understand deeper questions about black
holes
how does it for example if you throw
something to the black hole
uh after black hole evaporates and
goes goes away by hawking radiation what
happens to
the information of the things that you
sent in that was one of the puzzles that
we expect the answer to be a way to
resolve it and get the information out
but uh it it didn't it wasn't clear and
it still is not to be honest
i'm not clear how does the information
come out
so there are some simpler models in
which how the information may come out
can be understood in those cases so
lower dimensional examples there are
some toy models which do that so there's
some progress in that
i wouldn't say that this is a case where
i would say that we have make a big
breakthrough and really understanding
the big issue of black hole
but there are there are incremental
steps in that direction i would say
there are many other directions in
string theory which are
i would say still ongoing and it's
actually one of them which i
personally am interested relates to the
super symmetry again which we already
mentioned
so in fact uh i would turn it around
the fact that the fact that we didn't
discover supersymmetry and the fact that
our universe
does not enjoy this amazing symmetry
between
botons and fermions the supersymmetry is
telling us something about our universe
which is deep
and that deep fact is the following in
string theory we have two type of
uh universes that can exist the
universes that can last forever
and the universes that are temporary
that will decay away
and of course we would like to know
which one of these two universes we live
in
it turns out all the universes that we
know of in string
theory that last forever enjoys
supersymmetry
an unbroken version of the supersymmetry
should be realized in our universe at
least in the low energy
it's not realized which implies we do
not live
in the universe which will last forever
therefore
our universe is is going to be going
away
it's going to decay away so that's a
fundamental lesson that
lack of supersymmetry is teaching us our
universe is not going to last forever
so therefore the next question would be
what is the fate of our universe
when is it going to go away how is it
going to go away
so all these questions are exciting and
so this is just
leading us to the deeper question about
the nature so i think these kinds of
questions
i find among the most amazing questions
in string theory
that can actually teach us something
concrete about our universe that's what
those are the kind of questions i find
most exciting and i i would i'm working
on those kind of questions myself
i remember the uh the first time you
told me about those results i don't know
if you recall we just happened to run
into each other
in a cafe in cambridge massachusetts yes
and it's funny because i was in the
midst of finishing
my own recent book until the end of time
which has to do with possible
well part of the book is possible
endings of the universe so
i remember you told me about that way of
thinking about things and it certainly
made it into a book as a
as an endnote i wasn't able to work it
into the
main text itself but yes i mean thinking
about the ultimate fate
of the universe and to have any theory
that can give you insight
into questions of that sort is is of
course
inspiring again for those of you who are
just joining us
i'm speaking with cameron baffett this
is his new book over here
puzzles to unravel the universe those of
you who are here early on note that
kerman posed a puzzle early on in about
10 or 15 minutes
he'll describe the solution to that
puzzle but those of you who want to try
to still solve it
feel free to write down your solution
for the
most efficient highway network between
four
cities that are at all the corners of a
square
so what highway system would you use if
you were charged with doing it for the
least amount of money and your highway
system
the cost is proportional to the linear
length of the highway itself
so back to to questions of string
ethereum
and uh cosmology and unified theories
but one one thing before we get to that
one relates to puzzle yes
i'm going to give you another puzzle as
well but this puzzle i'm going to give
the solution to
okay so it's not part of that one but i
think it's interesting because
it also illustrates a point about what
does puzzle have to do with physics
yeah simple way so this is the puzzle
uh can something be falling and not
hitting
the ground that's the puzzle what is
falling what could be falling and not
hitting the ground
ever yeah no this sounds great are you
asking me that question or no no no no
no
i'm sure you can't say it immediately
but this is a puzzle
this is a puzzle that uh you would think
okay
something is falling and it's not
hitting the ground what could it be
what does it mean yeah and so this
sounds like you know it
can can be some kind of a word puzzle
it's not it's actual puzzle
and it's a puzzle that newton solved
newton's solved in the following way so
this is a question i
that you could raise is that there's a
moon and first of all the question is
why isn't the moon falling and the
second question is that okay if it's
falling then why is it not hitting the
earth
so those are the questions those those
are the questions and the answer that
newton gave was
so elegant which is the solution to this
puzzle so
so newton should get a price for that is
that
no actually moon is falling but it just
avoids hitting the earth now how does
that work
and this was this is beautifully
illustrated in this book in prison
mathematica which is shows that
if you start if there's no earth if you
get rid of the earth and if you look at
the moon
and if the moon is moving in some
direction it will continue going
straight
but if you have an earth instead of
going straight if you have anything
going straight
if you have like for example a
cannonball shooting going straight if
you have an earth it will fall on it so
if you have an earth
and if you have a cannonball shooting
from it will fall somewhere on the earth
if you if you shoot at a cannonball in a
with a higher speed it will go farther
down and farther and farther you can go
from the north pole let's say
all the way up to south pole of the
earth if you give it enough kick
but if you really give the huge kick it
will go all the way around
and it will continue going around so
what's happening is that
that ball is falling down because if it
wasn't before the earth it would go
straight
so having the earth causes that
cannonball to try to
to hit the ground it's falling namely
instead of going straight it's falling
just going not straight falling towards
the earth
but since the earth is round it keeps on
missing hitting the earth
so the cannonball or the moon itself is
the answer to the puzzle that's
that is falling if it wasn't for the
earth to go straight
so it is falling but it's not hitting
the earth because the earth is round so
it's like a game between
the roundness of this earth and this
falling of this moon
so this is an example where the puzzle
and the poetry and physics
all melt together and of course they can
be beautifully explained by mathematical
formula that newton discovered
but the whole thing is a simple looking
puzzle that kind of illustrates
the basic link between physics and
puzzles now it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful example
and it's perhaps worth noting that um
there was a period of time when you and
i and a few other of our friends would
find ourselves at the same christmas
party every year
and our you know tracy and my wife your
wife would all
leave us because we'd all start to talk
about these puzzles in one little corner
of the room and they're off you know
drinking and partying and having a good
time
and the one that you told me won one
christmas party
that was the following i'll just ask it
to the audience and again it's one that
people can try to
solve which is you have a a picture and
you want to hang the picture but you're
going to hang the picture from two nails
not from
one nail such that it's completely
stable if both
nails are secured to the wall but if you
remove one nail or the other and you
just leave the other
in the wall the picture will fall and uh
it's a it's a for those of you who are
more mathematically inclined
this puzzle gives you insight into a
subject of mathematics called homotopi
and it has to do with non-ability
homotope groups and
the non-ability nature of the homotopia
group of the plane punctured at two
points so for those who speak
mathematical language that's what this
is about
so again it's a so the the puzzle that
cumberland gave is a beautiful one that
puts the poetry of
physics and motion in the universe
together and here's one
again that cameron gave me that i i went
home
after that party we got home at like two
o'clock in the morning at six o'clock in
the morning i was up and my little
daughter who was like five at the time
we did it we took a picture we put it up
and yeah and you know
what we're getting that picture yes
absolutely yeah exactly
you gave me some good puzzles in fact
some of them my book about the
about the glasses and then the and the
symmetry breaking which is
part of that book so yes we have had
good fun with puzzles and the relation
between physics and
absolutely so i want to turn to one
other thing that's in your book
which was quite unusual
and and for me quite inspiring which is
you have a section on science and
religion
and and you know it's interesting
you know at the world science festival
which is what this program
is part of on various occasions we've
had programs on science and religion
and we do them because we find it a
fascinating conversation between
various distinct ways of of looking at
the world we also have conversations
between artists and scientists artists
and theology
theologians and philosophers so we'd
like science to reach out to the world
more broadly but i have to tell you
there were a number of scientists who
came back at us
really hard really angry that we were
having a program
on science and religion at the world
science festival they said what in the
world
does religion have any of any role there
and basically our answer and you know
tracy you know who's the co-founder with
me at the festival our our view was
what are you afraid of i mean any
conversation that's rich
that allows scientific ideas to be in
dialogue
with other qualities and perspectives on
the world it's a good thing
it's not something to to to sean but
nevertheless there can be
a recoiling and and so were you
concerned
about having science and religion like
like what led you
to include that that section in your
book well i think that
uh religion and science have many
commonalities so i think that
uh the the deeper truth
is what one is after and so uh
so of course uh as described in the book
i don't think that
i think there are ultimately different
realms of experience religious
experience and scientific experience and
i
kind of describe them in different ways
and i kind of
i was i wanted to share that you know
scientists are
also have views on this and i i gave
examples
you know newton uh how how religious he
was on some
more recent ones how they viewed for
example einstein how did he use
religion and so forth not so much as to
try to
come to a conclusion really about what
is the meaning of you know with what
should we do about religion what should
we do about science and so on
but to say this interplay between
between the two and
i i view in fact brought more broadly
what you just mentioned about the role
of religion and what
how scientists view in fact even broad
more broadly i feel that
there's this anti-philosophical bend in
which i would say religion is an example
of of that same thing
among scientists that somehow the
scientists feel that these should not be
this kind of thing is bad for science
and i think that's
as you just said and i completely agree
a little bit of immaturity
not to be able to describe and discuss
it and learn from aspects of it i think
this attitude that you know we know it
all and it's kind of like
everything else which is not can be not
formulated in this scientific form is a
waste of my time and so on i think
that attitude is is a little bit i think
short-sighted and i think
the human experience is much wider and i
think we should benefit from it we
should
incorporate it we should not be
antagonistic we should be welcoming and
try to
understand it and if there are pieces we
can say something science has
sheds light on some aspect we should and
vice versa if there's some
some shortfalls about the scientific
methodology we should bring in other
aspects and so
i think we should be open and i don't
feel that we should be worried about
the dialogue between different domains
of human thought or experience
so so in your book you do as you
mentioned go through in some very nice
sections
uh einstein and religion hawking and
religion
feynman and religion
what what i didn't see there was vapha
and
religion if you were to have included a
section
of that what would it have said it
wouldn't have said much it'd be empty
blank page
i think i think that i think that i i
want to leave that to the
to the it's a personal i view that as a
personal
feeling about what it is i think i think
the the
part of the problem is that the word
religion is not definable
and you know you might say x and
somebody might think what you mean by x
is a y and somebody might think it's a z
and so forth and you might say something
about x and they might misinterpret you
but
as if you're saying something about y
and they'll be complete misunderstanding
so i think anything i would have said i
felt
is that to be so qualified it would not
be possible to explain so i'd rather in
fact
generally not share my specific view
because it's not possible to
to to say it accurately enough but i
would say that i would say that the the
the view that that religion is in
conflict with science or sciences and
conflict
religion i don't buy that in general so
i think that
there's there's more harmony in in
religion and science
not any specific religion or specific
science or i think
in general the the modality of humans
thinking
is is not inconsistent with different
views of course you can
take a narrow view of one thing and then
you get contradictions
but broadly interpreted they are not
contradictory and
an example is this lamar trying to
getting motivated by religion
by the experience about you know how the
universe could have come from a tiny
small little primordial thing which
was ultimately led to the big bang
theory that he was advocating even
though einstein was against it and he
thought this is kind of mythology of
maybe religious mythology of some kind
so these kind of views
that you know other perspectives brings
we should welcome we should not
necessarily
be antagonistic towards and my view is
let's be open that's
generally that's my my bottom line is to
be open about this
so there's a lot of resonance between
what you're saying and and
my own views and sometimes when i
discuss
this in a public forum some have come
back at me and said well
you know you have the luxury of saying
things like that because you
live in a country that by and large
has certain kinds of not completely i
mean you know this also said that
you know can a presidential candidate
succeed
if they're willing for instance to say
that they're not religious that they
don't believe in god i mean that issue
has uh
never really been fully tested but
putting that to the side
you are in a unique position right
because you
come from iran when did you when did you
leave
iran what year well i came i came from
iran
just before my high school in 1977.
so i think if you hadn't left iran
do you think that your your views would
still be the same
as what you just described yes i still
go back to iran incidentally i visit
iran i give lectures there in physics
i uh i love visiting iran there are
they're very much interested in science
uh beautiful you know
universities and you know educational
centers and so on so there's
there's i mean one of the one of the
things i find about science is that's
borderless really it doesn't matter
where you are
you know what time you live and so it's
a borderless and timeless adventure in a
way and
i view you know me as an example i don't
feel like might be iranian or
american now or both iran american has
any impact
about my view about science i could have
been there
i could have been here it's just i
happen to be in the u.s working here but
i
i find this borderless adventure of
science is what's universal
and i think it'd be great to use science
as a vehicle to go between different
cultures and stuff clashing instead of
confronting so i think that science in
general for me is a glue
going between different cultures
different domains of human experience
like religion
like philosophy like art like poetry
all these things can be glued together
via science rather than
science being as differentiating and
saying this is right that's wrong this
is this this is that
and so forth so i think in a way i i
find
science as a as a refuge in in terms of
the craziness that we see around us in
terms of all these
conflicts that we see around us and
culturally or
otherwise so i think i don't see any
contradiction and i feel science can
bring things together rather than
differentiate them no i i totally agree
in fact i got um
a letter i've mentioned this in other
settings but it brings to mind what you
just mentioned i got a letter years ago
from an american soldier who was in
iraq in the craziness of everything that
was happening there and he wrote me that
he
had a copy of one of my books and that
it gave him the refuge
that you're talking about he could sort
of shut off the bombs
and the and and all and all the death
that was around him and all the fighting
and the
and the strife and just enter into
quantum mechanics or enter into
relativity
and it felt like a universal glue to use
the language that you're using that just
allowed him to cope with the difficult
situation
that that he was thrust into by virtue
of the
problems that beset the world so one
final error before we get to the
solution to the puzzle
uh you know i know that the question of
time
is is one that's very close to your
heart close to the heart of many
physicists
what is it where does it come from is it
fundamental where do you think we are on
that journey
to try to understand the true nature of
time
uh well
it's a very difficult and important
question of course and
we don't have a deep understanding even
of space which is in
something simpler so
i think that understanding how what
space really is
we have learned at least enough about
the nature of space and string theory to
know that
there is no there's no universal answer
that is
different corners of stan string
string theory leads us to different
pictures of
what is space and these are what we call
duality corners one
one corner and the other corner they're
compatible
different descriptions of what really
space is they look
in in contradiction they look not they
cannot be possibly
both be true but they're both true and
we have learned
not to say what is the right viewpoint
that is we have learned that for
the notion that what is the best
viewpoint is not a good question that
that
that that question of what is the best
viewpoint depends on the question being
asked
and so for example what is space we
learned that that is not a good
question because what is space ends up
having
good answer here or a good answer here
which look contradictory
so so we have learned that much about
space which is i would say much easier
question than the harder question
and more interesting question that
you're posing which is what is time
so for time we don't even have those
corners as well
navigated as space but i would interpret
i would expect you will have the same
kind of things emerging for
understanding time the time will not be
a unique answer what is time it will be
different
like snapshots pictures and for one
question that's a good answer for the
other one the other snapshot is a better
one
we're going to have these pictures next
to each other and
with the totality of all these pictures
we'll get a feeling about what is time
not for a single one of them not for one
or two of them but the totality
that's what physics is being driven
towards that's what string theory we
have
we have learned from the notion of
duality and the fact that this fabric of
different kinds of pictures come
together and there's not
one thing that is the right thing but
the totality is what explains it
so for space the recent results that
link
together the spatial fabric and quantum
entanglement is that a direction that
you think is
going to be continue to be a promising
one going forward that's certainly one
direction that has been explored
recently and has good results
about it i would say that is among other
things they're both
they're they're that's one of the
corners that i was alluding to
there are different corners that are
interesting so i would say each corner
has to be explored
uh not that any one corner is the answer
i'm not expecting the answer that this
is the answer
i'm expecting more totality the of the
experience that string theory is
teaching us which is
this duality picture that all of them
are perfectly fine depends on what
question you want to ask
if you want to ask questions hey that's
the best way of looking at if you ask
question b you go the other way
so yes the entanglement and how the
space and degrees of freedom about
individual bits of information how did
that come to describe the geometry of
space and so on
and how they are entangled is certainly
an example of one of these corners right
so let's now um turn to the solution to
the puzzle that that we gave at the
beginning of the discussion so maybe
just quickly because there are
there are many more people with us now
than were at the start so maybe uh just
re-uh reacquaint us with the nature of
the puzzle and now you're gonna give us
the solution
yeah so we have uh four towns uh four
cities a b
c and d on the four corners of a
square and the puzzle is to find the
shortest highway system which connects
all cities together
and the the highway system does not have
to directly connect
any city to any other city as long as
you can get from one to the other to
this highway system
that would be sufficient so that's the
puzzle
all right and what's the solution the
solution is the naive solution
one might think is let's go to the next
slide this one right the most naive
solution is that well you just go like
x now before we go to the next slide i
would like to say why would we even
guess the solution
well because it's symmetric right you
start with a square
and so the x is the one of the most
symmetric ones and it gets you
from any place to any other place you
want to get so that seems like the
answer so
so what is guiding us is the symmetry
the symmetry of the square
is guiding us towards the solution or
we might think there might be another
symmetric solution which is the next one
which is this one this is also symmetric
you know you have four
towns four cities you can have the whole
edges that would be another
possible symmetric solution so you say
either this or that
and then you begin to think you say wait
a second it cannot be this one
because if it's this one you can delete
one of the one of the
one of the roads and you still can't get
from any city to any other so that's
shorter
and you say in fact you can put that uh
city a because that the road can go from
any other place like the middle
so you might say well that looks that
looks the same length but actually you
can pull that
rod a little inwards and you can put it
a little inwards to be like that
with making an angle 120 degrees
and this turns out to be the shortest
and this is surprising this is confusing
because you start with the problem which
is symmetric
the four cities on the corners of a
square enjoy the symmetries of the
square
like 90 degree rotation but this highway
system does not enjoy this symmetry
in other words to get from city a to
city c
is a shorter path than getting from city
a to city b
even though city a and city b and city a
and dc have the same
distance relative to each other so
that's a puzzle so why is it that the
solution
does not enjoy the original symmetry
this fact we call
in physics spontaneous symmetry breaking
and this underlies
a lot of amazing phenomena around us in
the universe
spontaneous symmetry breaking is a key
to understanding
many things and in fact the ideas go
farther back
much longer history than we think we
originally thought we discovered this
idea in the past century the physicist
but actually it goes farther back to the
greek philosophers
so so early greek philosophers already
had they are very smart they had already
discovered that there is round
and they thought you know it's at the
center of the universe
and it's not moving so these are the
their observations was this
and so they were a bit puzzled why it's
not moving so they had to come up with
an explanation
of why it's not moving and they try to
use symmetry so
this is how they reason go to the next
slide we see
is the picture of the earth and they
said well okay suppose it moves
if it moves in some direction let's say
some direction
let's move it to the to the next slide
it goes somewhere
it breaks the symmetry so it cannot move
because it doesn't want to break the
symmetry
so they explained that the earth is at
the center of the universe and it's not
moving
because if it were to move in any
direction picks out the direction
and the very nature of picking a
direction breaks this spherical symmetry
around the earth
so it's not allowed so that's one of
them said this is a proof
earth is not going to move and then
aristotle didn't like the argument
he said nope not a good argument why
it's not a good argument
they asked said he reasoned as follows
he said well suppose
you put a person at the center of a
circle
and he put loaves of bread around that
person
symmetrically located on a circle
now the person is at the center of the
circle and you ask them whether or not
that person is going to move
well you would say no it's not going to
move because at the center of the circle
it breaks the
symmetry the circular symmetry were to
move of course you know that's not the
answer after a while the person feels so
hungry
person will move in some direction to
get that loaf of bread
so therefore the person breaks the
circular symmetry because that's not an
optimal place to be in being near the
bread and eating it is much more optimal
so
they say who cares about the symmetry
i'm going to get my bread i'll break the
symmetry
that's exactly what happened with that
highway system this shorter highway
system breaks the symmetry
and that's what the the highway system
chooses to do so it's broken symmetry
now what does it have to do with physics
you might ask
well first of all i would say that
spontaneous symmetry breaking is
imprinted in on our bodies
you see we live in a in a year in it on
the earth which basically has this
100 360 degree rotation symmetry around
us generally speaking
so you would think that our body should
also enjoy a 360 degree rotational
symmetry like
we should have we should have our eyes
all over a circle around
rather than just in the front but we
only have it in front you might ask
why why do we have our eyes only in the
front and not all over
all over the circle which would be more
symmetrical so
so somehow our body has broken the
symmetry of circular
360 degree rotation that's only in one
direction why is that
well the answer is aristotle so for the
same reason
you want to see where the food is to go
towards it in other words the motion to
go to
from one place to another is optimal in
a given direction and not you don't need
the 360 degrees
so with all the availability of
evolutionary
system of how the body is designed it
says it makes sense that much more
better uses of resources to just put the
eyes in the front because that's really
where you want to go anyhow
so the symmetry is broken because you
need to get to the food
and in more more details related to
more aspects of modern physics this was
the discovery of what's called the higgs
particle or the god particle or
what is the origin of the mass is
exactly the same circle that aristotle
drew
it turns out surprisingly a few thousand
years ago he already had the same
picture that we now draw in our
in our in our books or in papers talking
about
how particles get their mass namely if
you
think about they put the the potential
that
is around us they look it looks like a
valley
it looks like a hill and a valley and
they bought the top of the
the top of the this uh this hill area is
is the most symmetric point that person
that person is standing is the most
symmetric point but it's not an optimal
point
and it turns out that the optimal point
of course will be down on the
on the valley area and if you go down in
that valley here it turns out that the
there will be a mass related to how far
away you are from the symmetric point
so the being away from symmetry
translates to giving mass
so breaking symmetry means picking up
mass so this picture about how we have
the
eye how we get the mass all are related
into this
and they evolve into this simple idea of
this puzzle about the square
so the higgs gets hungry the higgs field
gets hungry and goes for the bread on
the uh on the
vanilla he's reflects our hunger and
that's why we become massive
that's good in fact in fact said nicely
that the
the the the one of the fields in his
model ate
ate another one another few that became
massive that's called higgs park who
gets its mass that way this is literally
this picture
that's fantastic well that's great so
thanks for that mini
mini discourse on on on connecting a
puzzle with real stuff in the world
around us those of you who were able to
solve that puzzle i don't know how many
it is but maybe world science
festival people will let me know i don't
know if it was they have written already
we have a winner from the audience
yeah wow from this channel i see we have
a winner
uh prior dash is that right
oh he's a he's a regular in in these in
these gatherings so that's
congratulations yes absolutely
congratulations i'll be glad to send my
book to you bryo that is that is well
done well done so we will work out the
details of that
so so again the book that we're talking
about and we have a slide for it but
just so you can sort of see it straight
out
puzzles to unravel the universe by the
guest today
professor kumar vaffa from harvard it is
available
all over the place you should get a copy
it is a it's a wonderful way
to introduce yourself to deep ideas of
physics
through an interactive and a real active
as opposed to sitting back and
letting the author preach to you which
is how most books are this is one where
you can get in on the action
and do things and then that will really
gain a intuition
for for the ideas that that professor
vaffa
is describing to you so kerman thanks so
much for
joining us for this uh conversation
thank you very much brian for this
session i really enjoyed it and
it's great to connect with your audience
and good luck with all the
great work we are doing with connecting
science to the wider public
i appreciate that thank you and we'll
we'll be in touch and uh no doubt our
paths will cross uh
sometime soon so thanks a lot maybe in
the cafe somewhere
very good all right guys so we're gonna
now just uh
move into the more ordinary q a
that we do in these discussions here i
hope i have oh i do have
maybe one of you out there one day is
going to send me a pair of glasses these
that i have today are cracked and broke
and they're not my wife's glasses at
least she is using them but uh
at least now i can see for half a second
so again sorry for looking ridiculous in
one way or another and yes prior dosh
congratulations on getting
the uh the solution really well done and
let me just scroll through and um
just take some uh general questions so
ramsey asks is allah personified by the
higgs boson
i'm not sure maybe this is one that i
should have kept the
kermit vapor on to answer but you know
when one uses the phrase god particle
when describing the higgs particle
perhaps it's worth mentioning
that you know there's a story behind
that the particle physicist and nobel
laureate leon letterman who
was instrumental in many of the ideas
associated with the
higgs particle higgs field and so forth
people were trying to find the higgs
particle for instance at the
fermilab accelerator where leon
letterman was associated for
for many years and it was very difficult
to find the particle nobody was finding
it so there was a general
joke going around that it was the god
damn particles because it was so
goddamn difficult to find this particle
and i think the story goes that when
leon letterman
was going to write his book and call it
the goddamn particle the publisher or
the editor
or audience surveys whatever suggested
that the god
particle would be a more poetic title
than the goddamn particle so it's just
to say
that no one is really associating the
higgs particle with any
religious tradition with any real
religious
outlook it is in some people's mind
a more fundamental particle than any
other because it endows
other particles with mass remember how
this goes the higgs particle
is the smallest piece of the higgs field
and higgs field is meant to be
a field a substance an invisible
substance i like to think of it as an
invisible
cosmic molasses that fills all of space
and as a particle tries to go through
space it has to plow
through the cosmic molasses and that
creates a resistance
and that resistance on the particles
attempt say to accelerate is what we
call
the mass of the particle so it's a
universal
mass giving field and the universal
quality can bring to mind the universal
quality
of god if you will so some people draw
the connection
in that way but again it is just
a field of physics like the
electromagnetic field
like the other fields that we make use
of the gravitational field and so forth
and it's a very special field but
mathematic is just one more field
so i wouldn't look for any theological
connections any deeper
than the poetic ones that i just
mentioned
okay heading onward sanjay
powwar what is dark energy
and again i think this is a question
that we've taken up a few times during
these various sessions but i'm always
happy to cover familiar ground it's
important
dark energy is another kind of field we
believe
it's a field like the higgs field that
does permeate space it's very related to
what i was just describing
but the difference with the dark energy
is that the amount of energy density in
the field
is such that the field has a significant
gravitational
influence on the universe the higgs
field does not have a significant
gravitational influence i mean it does
endow particles with mass
so you've got gravity in that story as
well but in terms of the intrinsic
source for gravity that the
higgs field is it's modest it's minor
whereas the
gravity sourced by dark energy is not
modest
it's not minor it's significant so
significant
that we believe it gives rise to the
repulsive gravitational push
that is driving space to expand ever
more rapidly
so it's again in some sense
analogous to the higgs field but in
terms of its impact on the way reality
unfolds it's quite different
because of the vast store of energy
that yields an important gravitational
contribution
that yields this accelerated expansion
having said that
let me not leave you with the wrong
impression the amount of energy
in the dark energy while enough to yield
a gravitational influence that's
observable is still a small amount of
energy
by everyday standards i did a
calculation and it's in my latest book
it's
yeah it's a calculation that you can do
on the back of an envelope i could
probably do it on top of my head but
i'll just try to remember the result
if you look at the amount of dark energy
in a given cubic meter of space
the energy in there could light a 100
watt
light bulb like the old variety right
well 100 watt doesn't matter the
technology but i'm having in mind not
the
100 watt equivalent of an led but
actually 100 watt light bulb
it could keep it illuminated for about
one about five trillionths
of a second i believe is the answer so
that's a tiny stretch of time to keep
that light bulb illuminated which is
just to say that
even though the dark energy has enough
energy to yield
an observable gravitational influence
the amount of that energy
on everyday scales is tiny absolutely
tiny but that's what that is so
enos abu salham asks what is dt
dx dt by dx
and that's an interesting interesting
question we all know what well i hope we
all know
what the x dt is right that's the
calculus expression for the
change in position divided by the change
in time
and the change in position over the
change in time is speed that's what we
mean by speed how far you go
divided by the duration the interval
that it takes you to travel
that distance what if you flip it upside
down and consider dt
dx and dtx is
a number well obviously it's one over
speed but you might ask yourself does
that come
into physics and in an interesting
in an interesting way and it kind of
does
because and i won't go through it in
detail but there's an analogous version
of that which is
d tau d t where tau is the invariant
interval
the invariant space time interval so you
can talk about detail dt or dtd tau
and that basically is the rate of change
of one clock
relative to the clock that's on your
wrist the clock that's on your wrist
measures invariant time it is intrinsic
time if you will and you can have other
clocks that are not moving relative to
you and you can ask yourself what's the
rate of change of your space-time
interval compared to
their space-time interval and that
is one way of thinking about einsteinian
time
dilation and why it holds true
because uh in some sense we are all
traveling through space time at the same
in variance speed which is equal to the
speed of light and if i get up and start
to move
i divert some of my motion through time
into my motion through space because i'm
now moving through space i'm not just
sitting still
and that notion of moving through space
affecting your passage through time
naturally emerges by considering things
like d
t d tau and d tau d t which is quite
related to
d t d x so if you want the details on
that i can send you to a little endnote
in my book the elegant universe i think
it's
i forgot which endnote it is but it's in
chapter two so you can see
how sometimes flipping the calculus
expressions upside down can give you
important and deep insights and that's
one specific
example of that all right let me i've
been only looking at the uh
the twitter questions let me see if
there are any
interesting uh not twitter the uh the
youtube questions i get my
social media sources mixed up but
let's see john olson
asks and this is from this is from
i guess this must be from facebook or
twitter a black hole question can two or
more massive black holes
change the geometry of a small black
hole's gravitational field in a way that
mass
can escape so it's certainly the case if
you've got multiple black holes around
[Music]
the geometry of space time at a given
point
is dependent upon all three of those
black holes so oftentimes when we write
down
a picture of a black hole we show a
schematic of the geometry but we show it
on its own
we don't show what it would look like if
there were a bunch of black holes
together with all the
various warpings of space time
overlapping
in interesting ways and we can do that
it's it's harder to do sometimes you
don't even have
exact solutions in these multi-body
versions of the general theory of
relativity but you can certainly
approximate the solution
quite well in many interesting
circumstances
and it's not that the new geometry
allows
the mass of a previous black hole
to escape but it does change for
instance
the trajectories that hawking radiation
which can escape from any black
hole the trajectories that those
particles that are emitted by a black
hole will take
so the detailed dynamics in any given
circumstance does intimately depend
upon the masses and the positions of
whatever black holes might be
in the environment and that can affect
the ways in which those black holes
evaporate
but it does not affect the classical
picture
that mass can't escape from a black hole
itself all right so what else do we have
here
uh chavoc mandal again from
and i'll go back to the to youtube feed
in a second
but from our social media feeds how can
we verify the predictions given by
string theory
we don't understand the quantum behavior
fully how can we look inside a quantum
world
it's too bizarre um so so a lot of
questions in there but the primary one
how can we verify the predictions given
by string theory
right that is a question that cameron
vaf and i discussed
just a little while ago and as he
mentioned
in principle if you built a sufficiently
large accelerator
not one like the large hadron collider
that can reach
you know depending on whatever units you
look at
10 to the four times the mass of a
proton
you know that kind of scale as
cumberland mentioned you need a
detector that's within an accelerator
that can reach 10 to the 20 times the
mass of a proton
so that's 16 orders of magnitude more
powerful than the large hadron collider
now where did that number come from well
within string theory
a key number is the planck mass
and the planck mass is about 10 to the
19 10 to the 20 times the mass of a
proton
and it's at the plank mass that in
conventional string theory
you would expect the extended nature of
strings to
be visible so that's why cameron
mentioned that 10 to the 20
number and so right so if we could build
an accelerator with that
magnitude of energy then at least in
principle we would
be able to test string theory so when
people say
that string theory is untestable
they really should qualify it in a way
that they might
roll their eyes and say well yeah of
course i mean that but they should
qualify by saying
we can't test string theory right now
but that does not mean that string
theory is untestable
and to some that is a distinction that
doesn't matter much but for those of us
within string theory it's a distinction
that really does
matter because if string theory were
permanently
untestable if there were a quality of
string theory
that said this is fundamentally not
testable by any means then
we really wouldn't be doing physics any
longer
you know some people say you know
psychoanalysis
is fundamentally untestable because
regardless of what the patient says
you can interpret it within the rubric
within the framework of freudian
analysis
and in that way there's effectively
nothing that the patient could say
that would fall outside that template
but that's not the case with string
theory it's just that we have limited
experimental capacities we advanced
human beings here in the 21st century
have limited experimental capacities
and string theory is such a bold theory
it is such an ambitious theory that some
of its most
iconic qualities just don't emerge at
everyday energy scales
the theory is so bold and ambitious that
some of its key qualities
emerge at fantastically larger scales
such as the scales that kerman vapha was
mentioning so
so how do we test string theory we may
get lucky excuse me half a second here
we may get lucky and one day
some clever einsteinian level string
theorist or
einstein squared level of
capacity that person comes along and
says
look at this and they do some fancy
mathematical manipulation and
out pops some prediction of string
theory that we could test
with existing technology and we thought
that we might have that
with super symmetry that's a quality of
string theory that
might be measurable at energies
like that of the heart large hadron
collider but we've not succeeded
and that might mean that that quality of
strength here is wrong
and kerman mentioned some of the
implications of that
if string theory is fundamentally not
realized
in a universe that is governed by string
theory that's the big assumption that
strength here is right
but the flavor of is relevant say to our
universe is a flavor that does not
involve the super symmetric quality at
least at
accessible energies that might suggest
that the universe is unstable
and it might suggest that you know i
don't think he couldn't mention the
number but
it could be that within you know a
factor of 10 100 or a thousand times the
current age of the universe our universe
disintegrates
and that is a possibility that i
explore in my book and in
the book until the end of time the
specific version that kerman mentioned
as i
noted there is just really an endnote
but the possibility that our universe
might disintegrate
in that time frame is one that we may
have to
at some level accept but the point for
shivok mandal's question
is that supersymmetry was one of those
qualities that
emerges from the mountaintop of string
theory and rolls down and in principally
thought
might come to rest at energy scales
accessible to the large hadron collider
but that seems not to be the case but
there may be other qualities
but if there are no such other qualities
or if we don't have the brain power to
extract those other qualities
then the real way to test string theory
may be to wait until we have
fantastically
powerful energetic accelerators or
whatever kind of
machine takes the place of acceleration
the far future
so it's very much up in the air now you
can ask yourself so
does that mean that you shouldn't work
on string theory and clearly someone
like kumar papa says
that's the wrong reaction there are the
corners
of reality that he made reference to
which string theory can illuminate
now you might say well how do we know
it's reality you don't you don't
but that's what being at the cutting
edge of science is regardless of what
subject you're in
you're pushing into frontiers that you
don't know
at least if you're doing theoretical
work whether they're relevant to the
real world that we live in and you take
a chance
and some people find it very exciting to
take that chance
and they go on into string theory or
other speculative fields or other
scientists that want
hey i'm working on a project and i want
it to be done in two or three months
and regardless of what the answer is i
want it to be interesting enough to
write a paper on it
and there's a lot of science that can be
done that way interesting science it's
just a different
way of engaging with reality
so it's all a matter of personal choice
okay deepak ponmar what is what is an
axion an axion
is a hypothetical particle that
naturally emerges from certain attempts
to solve
famous long-standing problems in
particle physics
so there's a a problem called a strong
cp problem
it afflicts our understanding of the
strong nuclear force
c and p have to do with certain
symmetries
of the mathematical equations charge
conjugation
parity symmetry and when you look
in the strong nuclear
force the equations that we study there
are certain terms that in principle
could be there but they seem to be
highly suppressed based on
the impact that they would have on
experimental predictions that are not
observed
and so the question is how do you argue
that these terms
should be suppressors or a natural way
to suppress them
and it's an interesting long story but
one way of suppressing them is to
look at a certain kind of symmetry a u1
symmetry for those of you that like
mathematical analyses and associated
with that solution
is this particle called the axion and
the reason why the axion is spoken of
in more recent
descriptions of the universe is that
it may be a dark matter candidate it may
be the dark matter is perhaps a better
way of saying it
it is a dark matter candidate and the
more
traditional candidates that people have
thought about for decades
weekly interactive massive particles or
so-called wimps
not the nicest of names for these
particles but
these particles naturally emerge from
supersymmetry which again may or may not
be relevant to low energy physics
but we've searched for these wimps and
we haven't found them
or i don't know if that's the best
description
there have been moments when we thought
we found them and then the experiments
could not make a sufficiently convincing
case
that the community of physicists had
come around to believe that the dark
matter had been detected so
just about everybody in physics is of
the mindset that we don't know
yet what the dark matter is and with all
these experiments looking for one class
of particles called wimps
and not finding them to most people's
satisfaction
other candidates have bubbled up to the
surface and this axion particle is
is one such possibility so
that's what an action is and that's why
we're interested in them
and we just have to wait and see whether
additional information
comes around to perhaps convince us that
axions are indeed the dark matter
so diego asks is symmetry a property
of the universe or a property of our
understanding
of the universe and and
that's a variant on on the deep question
is is mathematics a quality
of the universe or is mathematics simply
the language that we humans use to
describe
the universe and both questions diego's
question and my
variation on that question are
questions that people argue about all
the time
right i mean you look out
and you see patterns in the world
and in order to encapsulate those
patterns
in succinct descriptions one of the
things that you do
is look for symmetries right i mean a
circle
is the prototypical example and a circle
is highly symmetric in the sense that if
you rotate it through any angle
around its center it looks the same and
because it looks the same
that means you don't have to describe
every single point on the circle
if you have described one point on the
circle you've described
all points on the circle because via the
symmetry
they all look the same that's a very
simple example of the power of symmetry
allowing you to
reduce the complexity of your
description
you can just describe one point on the
circle describe its distance from the
center and you are
done because every other point is the
same distance from the center
and therefore you don't need to talk
about them in any explicit manner
and they are all related by a rotational
symmetry around the center
now you know is the circle a real thing
you know plato had in mind that there
was this other
meta universe or perhaps real universe
where perfect circles lived and perfect
triangles and squares and all of the
the perfect versions of the shapes that
we described
they are out there they're real but
they're in
this other parallel reality
others think about circle as a figment
of the human mind
it is something of our own making
that we impose on the external world and
when we find things
in the world that look like circles
we impose this pristine version of the
circle upon them
and in that way we model stuff that's
out there in
the world via these
constructs of the human mind right so
simple example right so right here i got
this little
bottle top you know it looks pretty
circular and if i were to describe it
i'd say
the two-dimensional projection of this i
would say it is a circle
but in keeping with diego's question we
all know that
this bottle cap is not really a circle
if you were to zoom in on it right i'll
get closer and closer and closer you see
that it has rough edges associated with
it
if you took an electron microscope in
there
and you'd even be able to see the ridges
or maybe even see
the atomic constituents
that are rag tag arranged in something
that approximates or without a real
circle
so that's the question are these ideas
of symmetries
talking about real stuff in the external
world or
is it our description of the external
world so if i was to give you my answer
diego i would say it's our description
of the world i i've come to the
viewpoint in recent years that
mathematics is a powerful
language of human invention for
describing things in the world
and within that mathematical language
there are certain idealized
qualities and among those idealized
qualities
are things that are known as symmetries
circular symmetry is one but they're
more abstract
symmetries that we usually use the
mathematical
field of lead groups and li algebras to
describe those symmetries
and i think that these are powerful
tools that we invented to describe the
patterns of reality
but to say that they're actually out
there in the world
[Music]
that's a step that i used to take that i
that i don't take
at least at the moment so diego long
answer to your short question
i would say that the symmetry is a
property of our understanding
of the universe and that understanding
is officially powerful that it can make
predictions about things that are out
there
so it's not as though it's solid
solipsistic
it's not as though it's all happening in
here we can use that
symmetry and that map to make
predictions and the predictions are
borne out by experiment
so it's not as though it's all limited
to stuff that happens inside of our
heads but i do think that the
description
is something of our own making okay
[Music]
local titans asks is there a possibility
of more fascinating undiscovered
behaviors of space-time that might even
more complex than our
imagination and local titans i like that
name local titans
i think the answer of course i have to
say is yes is that possible yeah
i mean the history of physics is a
history where
we're astounded by the
concepts that the mathematics forces
upon us
i mean black holes are absolutely
beautiful example
einstein writes down his general theory
of relativity in 1915
a mathematical description of space time
within a handful of years we learned say
from carl schwarzschild
who solves the equations first one to
solve the equations we learned about
this possibility of black holes they
weren't called black holes back
in 1917 rather they
were called dark stars or frozen stars
but this idea that there might be
this monstrous structure in the cosmos
that sucks in
matter that gets too close it doesn't
let anybody escape
this ultimate warp in the fabric of
space-time
it comes out of the mathematics it does
not come out of imagination
and in fact it was so shocking that
einstein's imagination couldn't really
cope with it einstein wrote a handful of
papers
i think the last one was 1948 where he
was trying to argue that black holes
would not be real that they were just a
mathematical figment
that emerges from his equations but not
real
but as you all know i don't have a
picture here i don't know how
if our team can grab a hold of the the
famous
picture of a black hole that was just
taken a couple of years ago
right that's not the only evidence we
have for black holes we had
the orbit of stars around the center of
our milky way galaxy and we had other
indoor we had gravitational waves
the particular ripple in the fabric of
space time that we
detected back in 2015 the
supercomputer simulation showed that it
had to emerge from
from the collision of two black holes
but now we actually have
in some sense photograph of a black hole
shep doleman and the event horizon
telescope they
took this famous there it is we took
this famous photograph right
so look at the journey from einstein in
1915
to the imagination of carl schwarzschild
1916 1917
through the observations of many in
culminating with the image that you just
saw
so yeah local titans i think that
pattern
will be played out again and again as we
go forward
and there will be increasingly strange
and weird
ideas that don't come from human
imagination that come from the
mathematical description of the world
and some of those ideas will be wrong
and some of them will be right and some
of them will be experimentally
confirmed just like the idea of black
holes was so i do think
that that is the pattern that we will
see persisting
going forward little doubt on that
okay let me go back to our questions
here
nylesh asked sir can you please explain
bell's experiment
and hidden variables
i can i can i'll give you an abbreviated
version it's a beautiful story
it's one that you know as i'm wondering
have we actually done a full world
science festival program
on bell's inequality and entanglement
it's certainly
been mentioned in many of our programs
it's certainly in a
theatrical piece that we are now
developing anew on quantum mechanics
it's called spooky action the drama of
quantum mechanics
so those of you who liked light falls
our
theatrical exploration of the general
theory of relativity and those of you
have not seen it again i'm not supposed
to do this but i don't care
there's a if you go to this youtube
channel
they should not have it up it's called
the documentary channel i don't know who
it is
we didn't put it up because we weren't
allowed to
they're not allowed to either but
whatever uh
so you can watch it on the documentary
channel that's a
theatrical exploration of the discovery
of the general theory of relativity
uh if you like it leave a comment there
i always love to see if you don't like
it don't leave a comment
please but if you do like it leave a
comment i'd love to see those
those positive comments but we're
developing
a version of that kind of presentation
for quantum mechanics but anyway back to
the question the spookiness in spooky
action the title of that piece
is quantum entanglement and here's the
story very very quickly here's the story
so einstein himself in 1935 now in the
85th anniversary of that famous paper
einstein and two colleagues showed
that according to the math of quantum
mechanics you could have two very
distant particles
that behave as though they are one the
canonical example this is not the
example that einstein used this is an
example that comes from david bowm
a wonderful character in the unfolding
of the history of quantum mechanics
but a given particle can be either
spinning up or spinning down
that's the nature of particles and in
einstein
and colleagues reworking of that idea
with this bomium
version you can have two distant
particles that are both
spinning up and spinning down at the
same time they're both in a fuzzy
mixture spinning up and spinning down
and here's the thing you can go and
measure one of those particles and cause
it to snap
out of the quantum haze according to the
math
that einstein and colleagues showed the
other particle would also snap
out of the quantum haze at exactly the
same moment even though you didn't do
anything to it let me see if i can get
in front of the camera here correctly
so up and down the same time you measure
say the one in my right hand boom
snap up the one on my left hand snaps
down
oh come on be in the frame it's so
counter-intuitive how to move these
things
so it's weird it's spooky you do
something in one location it influences
a particle another location einstein
said no no no no no there's no such
thing as spookiness
he said but this experiment is really
showing you is that these particles that
you thought were in a fuzzy mixture
up and down at the same time they were
not they were always
up or always down and when you measured
it and you found it spinning up it
always was
up and the other one when you measure it
you find it spinning down it was always
down
and if it was always down then there's
no spooky connection it's not like
when you measure the particle in new
york it affected the particle in
california because
the one in new york was always up the
one in california was always down
period end of story no spooky connection
between them
whatsoever so who's right
that's the question is there spookiness
as the math of quantum mechanics
says in quantum entanglement or is there
no spookiness
as einstein's interpretation of
the experiment would suggest
and many people at the time thought this
was not a question that could really be
answered
wolfgang paulie i think described this
as
a question that was no better than
asking how many angels can
dance on the head of a pen it's just not
answerable
why is it not angerable because paulie
was saying look if you want to know if
this particle was spinning up and down
simultaneously and when you measured it
it snapped out of the haze
or if it was always up and when you
measured it it was just revealing its
pre-existing
characteristics paulie says how can you
ever test that because to test that
you've got to measure it
and the point is once you measure it
it's always spinning up or down you can
never catch it in the act of spinning up
and down simultaneously
[Music]
john bell to answer your question and
whose question was this
this is uh nye luscious question john
bell came along and found
surprisingly found an observational
consequence
of a particle being in a fuzzy mixture
save up and down at the same time
even if you're not measuring that
particle
there's an indirect influence of a being
in that fuzzy mixture of up and down
that is measurable you have to be more
clever
you can't just brute force measure the
particle and say well it's up
and therefore i don't know if it was up
and down beforehand or if it was just
up beforehand you got to do something
more involved something more clever
and that's what john bell did he found a
more clever experiment
that could give you insight into whether
particles have definite features before
you measure them
or whether they're in a mixture before
you measure them and to most people's
satisfaction
that proposed experiment which is then
carried
out concludes that einstein was not
right on this
idea that particles really can be in
this fuzzy mixture
and it only becomes definite upon
measurement or observation or
interaction of some sort and to really
understand the details in that
explanation
it's you have to really look at it more
closely and
in in chapter um i don't know
chapter four of fabric of the cosmos i
go through i think it's that chapter
a long time ago now i go through a very
detailed
analogy that i i believe really captures
the heart and soul
of john bell's inequalities in the
experimental state
of checking those inequalities yielding
the insight that i just described that
at least when it comes to definite
properties einstein's view seems not to
be borne out by the observations that's
one place where you can learn about
non-mathematically
but the math is not hard so for those of
you who are familiar with linear algebra
a little bit of quantum mechanics you do
not need much
to really understand the original papers
so i would encourage you to do that but
nilesh i hope that gives you the basic
idea of
john bell and quantum entanglement
okay so
um just trying to find a good question
to take us
in a in a different direction
um so siamak rajyabhi asks
can you explain eric valente's theory
versus the general theory of relativity
and um again that's a that's an involved
story to
to describe in in detail but i can give
you the flavor for it
so often we talk about
general relativity as a fundamental
theory of
the world now earlier we discussed what
does that really mean
is it stitched into the fabric of the
world the general theory of relativity
or is it a human description
of the stuff that happens out there in
the world
and again i don't know the answer
to that question but a related question
is
is the general theory of relativity a
fundamental theory of the world or
might it actually emerge from yet more
fundamental considerations and with eric
verlinde and and others
ted jacobson maybe was the first who
started along a very similar trajectory
asked themselves could it be the case
that just understanding statistical
mechanics thermodynamics
in a gravitational setting might be
enough
to extract einstein's equations
as opposed to posit einstein's
equations and and these studies have
been successful in in in in certain ways
so without even knowing einstein's
equations but knowing certain very basic
features
about thermodynamics and certain very
basic features of quantum mechanics
these these folks have been able to
extract
aspects of einstein's general theory of
relativity and
thereby come to the conclusion
that einstein's theory is an emergent
theory
an effective theory a theory that comes
into play
in certain contexts but rests upon more
fundamental physical principles and
that's an exciting
idea it's it's resonant with a lot of
things that
we think about and discuss and work on
in string theory i mean for linda is a
string theorist
i think he would call him a string he
would call himself a string theorist at
heart
i don't think that is a description that
he would consider inaccurate
although more much more broad and is
thinking
about things but in string theory there
are many who've come to the conclusion
as we began to talk about with kermit
in the first hour that space and time
are not fundamental that they themselves
are emergent
that's a spectacularly interesting idea
because every formulation of physics
you go back to to to anything that
newton wrote down or anything that
galileo was thinking about or anything
that really happened after and all of
these theories
certainly assume a pre-existing spatial
environment
a pre-existing notion of time that
allows for a dynamism
that allows for things and systems to
change over time you can't talk about
change over time without
time being part of your description from
the get-go
but these newer ideas are suggesting
that space and time are not fundamental
that there's a description of reality
where
when you look at the basic vocabulary
you don't even need to use the word
space and time
to get the theory off the ground and
then space and time
come into play when you apply that
theory in certain domains of reality
such as the domains that you and i
are inhabiting at the moment but the
space and time
and the description that comes from the
general theory of relativity of space
and time
may all be emergent
may all come into play
in certain environments but are not
fundamentally part
of how the world is put together that's
the basic idea
[Music]
uh andrew haney asked will you present a
gender relativity course on world
science you
[Music]
and andrew i i think the answer to that
is yes
and just putting all cards on the table
you know that i have this special
relativity course and you may also know
although some of you may not be aware we
just released
the the video of the non-mathematic
the non-mathematical version of the
special
relativity course it's called spacetime
and einstein we released it just a few
weeks ago we filmed it a while ago of
course
but we took it out of the world signs
you universe
and put it out just on our youtube
channel we put on two youtube channels
actually the world science festival
youtube channel and the world science u
youtube channel it's out on both and
yeah yeah i was surprised it's gotten
a lot of activity a lot of views i think
between those two
channels has gotten over 300 000 views
in the last few weeks that's fun to see
people are interested and that sort of
motivates me
to to go ahead and maybe create the
general relativity course
and also the quantum course i'm thinking
the quantum course i might do first
we're actually building a little studio
up here where we are
we are huddled waiting for this virus to
pass
and if we can get that studio built
hopefully it's in the next month ideally
one of the projects that we'll do in
there is to film a quantum
course for world science u analogous to
the special relativity course that
already exists and the general
relativity course so
so i will give you a tentative yes
andrew i don't know the time scale for
the general activity course but i'm
i'm going to go out on a bit of a limb
here and i'm going to try to get the
quantum course
done by like december january something
like that and again though i'm going to
try to do a non-math version that's
embedded in the math version
so that those of you who don't like the
math can take the non-math version
and if you feel motivated you can then
watch some of the surrounding material
and see the
the mathematics behind some of these
ideas
so that's certainly a project that is
moving from the back
burner heading toward the front burner
so we'll see how
how that affects uh things going forward
so um
as can the casimir effect describe
gravity at the quantum level
and that's a very interesting idea amjad
because the casimir effect
i think i i hope well maybe i should say
what that is
i don't know if i don't have any show
and tell with me so i just have to use
my hands
but if you take two metal plates and you
bring them very very very close together
there's an interesting force that comes
into play if these plates i mean forget
about gravity just for the moment
if these plates are have no electric
charge you wouldn't expect to be any
force between them it doesn't matter how
close together
how far apart if they're neutral objects
and you're forgetting about gravity
then there's no other force that would
act but quantum mechanically there is a
force
and it has to do with the undulations
of the fundamental fields like the
electromagnetic field because the
quantum undulations of the field
outside the plate is fundamentally
different from the quantum undulations
that
quantum mechanics allows inside the
plates and that difference creates an
imbalance
that in certain circumstances can force
the plates to come together or in other
geometries can force the plates to push
apart
and that force is called the casimir
force of the casimir effect
and the beauty of it is it's measurable
casimir did these experiments in 1948
dutch physicist i'm pretty sure his
dutch physicist
did his experiments in 1948 so it was
measuring the difference between the
quantum undulations
in the vacuum between the plates versus
exterior to the plates and and so it's
this beautiful macroscopic way
of testing quantum effects can you use
those ideas to test gravitational
effects
and the answer is definitely yes the
question is is it is it detectable
and there's a beautiful relevant paper
to these ideas
that i just was reading by
nobel laureate frank wilcheck and
an old friend of mine i guess i can call
him an old postdoc of mine
actually named uh malik parrik
who is now at in arizona
is it arizona state university or
university of arizona i'm not
i get those mixed up i think it's i
think it's arizona state university
and they've written an interesting paper
trying to see whether
you know quantum effects quantum effects
analogous to the cashmere effect
really that come into play when you
measure gravitational waves
could those subtle quantum effects be
used to perhaps gain insight or detect
gravitons themselves gravitons are the
the quantum
of the gravitational field photons or
the quantum of the electromagnetic field
right you're seeing me right now
because photons are emanating from your
screen
traveling banging into your eye hitting
your retina causing a cascade of other
particle interactions inside your eye
sending a signal down your optic nerve
to your brain that's how you are seeing
me it's all coming from
the seed of photons interacting with
your eye
gravitons do for gravity what photons do
for the electromagnetic field
so there's a debate among some
physicists as to whether gravitons are
actually real
this is where that remark i mentioned in
the first hour when i was talking to
kumpapha
that freeman dyson seem to not think
that
gravitons are real but if they are real
then what will check and and malik park
have suggested is that
these kind of gravitational wave like
technologies
properly used and interpreted might give
us
insight into the nature of gravitons or
even the reality of gravitons
so so yes in principle the answer to
that question
is yes sanjay
says i'm like team physicist young
sheldon
thanks for sharing sanjay i uh i'm not
sure how to respond to that but i guess
that i guess that's a good thing
so i will uh leave that i will leave
that
at that anas asks what's the natural log
of a matrix and that's a slightly
technical question
but what we do in physics or mathematics
more generally
when you want to talk about operations
on
a matrix the operations that we know
easily
for matrices we know how to add matrices
you know how to multiply
matrices those are the easy things to do
and so what we do is when we look at
more complicated functions of a matrix
where like with a natural log you don't
really know what to do when you apply
the two matrix
we do know how to create a series
expansion
that approximates the
function that you might be talking about
for instance you know for an exponential
which is the inverse of the natural log
well how do you exponentiate a matrix
well we know
how to have a series expansion for an
exponential e to the x
you know it's 1 plus x plus x squared
over 2 factorial plus x cubed over 3
factorial that's a series expansion for
an exponential
if you were to not put a matrix up there
in the exponent for an exponential you'd
say what is
e to a matrix i don't know but if you
plug that matrix into the series
expansion you do know what it is
one becomes the identity matrix
x is just the matrix itself plus x
squared over
2. you know how to square a matrix
square matrix you multiply it by itself
and so on
so if you have a series expansion then
you can use that as the definition
of that function of a matrix and you do
have a series expansion within limits
for the natural logarithm and that's how
you define the log
of a matrix so thanks for that question
hope that wasn't too technical
but that is how typically people
interpret
the natural log of a matrix
mr space asks hello mr green
if space is expanding everywhere does
this mean
that at the nano scale or even smaller
that the distance between
atoms is also expanding and
the answer to that question is is yes
and no what do i mean by that
well when you talk about space expanding
on large scales you're talking about
scales that are so large
that the gravitational influence between
entities within space is so small
that the attraction between
them is not influenced by gravity or in
fact any of the other forces
of nature and therefore you just focus
upon the movement that comes
from the dynamics of spatial expansion
itself and indeed that can drive distant
galaxies to move away from each other
when you talk about the same ideas on
small scales like nanoscales or you
don't have to go that small talk about
these scales right
are the atoms in my broken glasses are
they moving apart from each other
because of the expansion of space and
generally we say
no why don't we say no we say oh god my
glasses are so dirty it's kind of gross
we say no i'm going to clean my glasses
as i'm answering the question we say no
because my glasses
are held together by the electromagnetic
force
not strong enough to hold this arm on
the electromagnetic force was
overwhelmed there
by like my dog's teeth or something
sitting on my glasses caused it to crack
but the atoms in my lenses they're held
together by the electromagnetic force
which is stronger than the outward
swelling of space
and that's why the atoms in here are not
moving apart in the way that that you
suggest mister space
but if the expansion of space were to
get stronger
and that's possible if the expansion of
space is not only
speeding up but the rate of speed up is
speeding up
then it's possible that in the future
the outward swelling of space is so
powerful that it would cause the atoms
in the lens to move apart shattering my
glasses
and it would indeed cause the electron
orbiting the nucleus of an atom to
expand away from the nucleus
causing the atom to disintegrate
and if that were the case then that kind
of expansion
would destroy everything so as of today
the answer to your question mr space is
no
atoms are not being driven apart by the
swelling
of space but in the future if the
expansion picks up in its
ferocity then individual atoms could be
moved apart from each
other and even electrons within atoms
could be driven apart from the nucleus
causing everything to fall apart that
is a potential future that
that we potentially face
okay so what else i'm going to go back
to uh
my uh other list of questions that comes
in
from social media things anything fun
there
um let's see uh
so kaphil sharma asked a question just
like mr space
but i'm not going to answer it again but
very close
um so nomad asks uh
in inflation or cosmology more general
we imagine that the earth is 13.8
billion
light years away from the big bang i'm
not sure i would exactly say it that way
so i'll come back to that in a second um
and that means that the
age of the universe for us is 13.8
billion years i'll buy that
what about celestial bodies that are
farther away and can't be seen by us so
a number of questions in there nomad
nomad which is your full name
so i wouldn't say that we're 13.8
billion years
13 8 billion light years away from where
the big bang took place i would not say
that
i understand what you mean by that what
you mean by that is
if we were to see the big bang like
let's be concrete when we look at the
cosmic microwave background radiation
which was released just you know a few
hundred years
after the big bang those photons have
been traveling toward us for
on the order of 13.8 billion years so
they
emanated from a point in space that
is 13.8 billion light years away at
least when that photon
left at that point in space so
so so what does that what does that mean
when we talk about
a photon that's been traveling through
space for so long and i just realized
what i just said was a little bit wrong
so i should really clarify that
um so so when we see something in space
we are seeing it of course as it was a
long long time ago
and when we say that the universe is
13.8 billion years old what we mean
is that the big bang happened that long
ago
and therefore where were to actually see
that event
you'd be seeing an event that happened
far away in the distant past
but you see i wouldn't say that the big
bang happened
at a distant location what i would say
is all locations that are now separated
were on top of each other at the moment
of the big bang so the big bang happened
where you are where i am where
everything
is located because all those locations
that are now distinct for the same
location so clarification number one
i would not say that the big bang
happened 13.8 light years away from
us there was a bang that happened there
but we don't need to distinguish that
bang from our bank because
those locations were the same location
but in terms of the second question in
terms of celestial bodies that are even
further away that we can't see yeah
we make a very sharp distinction in
physics between the
universe and the observable universe
and the celestial bodies that we can't
see nomad nomad
are in the universe but they're not in
the observable universe
and so we make assumptions about what
those celestial bodies might be like we
generally assume that they're pretty
much
like what we recognize
by close examination of things in the
observable universe but that could be
wrong
it could be that the observable universe
is completely misleading it suggests
that their stars
galaxies and planets and things of that
sort
and we imagine that well beyond that
there are stars galaxies
planets and things of that sort but it
could be that
beyond the observable universe i don't
know maybe there's nothing
maybe there's all sorts of other stuff
that we've never even thought of
that's quite possible since we can't see
it
yet or perhaps ever depending upon how
the universe expands
it's difficult for us to say anything
our theories are well
commensurate with this assumption of
homogeneity that what we see here
is a good guide to what we see out there
you know just like you know you look at
one little chunk of a circle
even if you weren't looking at the rest
of it if you know it's a circle as we
discussed before that one chunk
gives you a lot of information about
other chunks on the circle
we're looking at one chunk of the
universe right now
does it give us insight into other
chunks that maybe as nomad
nomad asks too far away for us to see
and we don't know the inflationary
theory
allows for on incredibly large
distances for the universe to be quite
different
it allows for us to be part of a
multiverse where those other
universes might have radically different
properties
from the properties of our universe so
the homogeneity
might be a local homogeneity that sort
of works in our
environment but if you go into other
environments that emerge from
other universes that come from other
bangs in the inflationary theory
the physics and properties of those
universes might be quite different
and that's that's an exciting idea and
one that has been harnessed in string
theory to give answers to questions like
why does the dark energy have the
particular value in our universe that it
does
we've not been able to answer that
question through a straightforward first
principles calculation in our universe
so what have some people suggested well
they suggest hey
what if there are other universes as
nomad nomad
notes and what if as nomad nomad's
question suggests
those other universes have quite
different properties and in particular
what if those other universes
have different amounts of dark energy
and moreover
what if the spectrum of possible amounts
of dark energy out there in this
multiverse
varies enormously such that
in effect every possible
value of the dark energy is realized in
some universe that's out there
now in that totality of universes that
would mean that
every possible value of the dark energy
is realized which means
that the value that we have doesn't need
explanation it's just one value
of the spectrum of all possible values
that
are out there and therefore it had to be
that there was one universe with our
particular value and here we are
living in that universe the analogy that
i like to use it's imperfect
but you know if you go to uh
if you go to a suit shop you're looking
for a dinner suit
and they pull one off the rack
and it and it fits should you be
surprised that they had a dinner jacket
that fit you
well if they had only one size then that
would be incredibly lucky and you should
be surprised
but most stores don't have just one size
they have all possible sizes you know
within reason you know they don't have a
continuum of sizes they have all
possible discrete sizes between some
small and large
and within that spectrum of
possibilities of course there's going to
be one that pretty much fits you because
they've got
all possible suit sizes on the rack
so any you know in a realm that had one
size
surprise in a store that has one size
you should be surprised in a store that
has all sizes you should not be
surprised that one fits you
now take that idea to the universe if
there's a multiverse
then all possible sizes are out there so
you shouldn't be surprised at our size
by which i mean our amount of dark
energy is out there
if the universe was not a multiverse if
we were more like that suit
shop that had one size suit then yeah we
should be surprised by the particular
value of the dark energy that we've
measured it's some strange
number that we don't have any insight
into
but here's where nomad nomad's question
helps us out
if the other universes exist and if
they've had different values for the
dark energy
we're just one of the collection and
that's a potential solution
to the amount of dark energy in our
world the solution is
you don't need to worry about we're just
one of the complete collection
that is out there all right back to
questions on our youtube feed here
[Music]
rob vandenberg asks where do you stand
on the existence of karma
or luck well what i would say is
we like to use that language
and we like to impose those concepts
and those concepts as high-level
human ideas for some are useful
some like to think hey you know i do
good to the world
and that is good for my karma and some
good will come to me
and when that good comes people in this
way of thinking about
things say yeah they're like oh yeah
that confirmed it i did that nice thing
last year
and now this nice thing happens to me
and there's a certain kind of
coherence and explanatory
satisfaction that comes from that way of
looking at things
if you view karma and luck
in that light as higher level human
ideas that some people find
useful and satisfying and gratifying
then i think that's a
a fine a fine kind
of structure to give coherence to
experience
but fundamentally do i believe that
there truly is something called karma
do i fundamentally believe that
collections of particles come together
and do something
good today because collections of
products came together and did something
that we humans consider
good yesterday no i don't i think the
particles that make up
matter that make up us that make up our
brains
are doing what they do because of the
laws of physics
not because of some higher level
conceptual framework of luck or
karma those ideas are what we humans
employ
to try to make sense of experience and
in that regard they can definitely play
a role
of helping people make sense of
experience but fundamentally
no there's no such thing as karma that
you'll find in the fundamental laws of
physics
there's no such thing as luck that
you'll find in the fundamental laws of
physics
particles do what they do because they
are
following the fundamental laws now
whether we have those laws or not
i don't know i've said this before it
could be that we have those laws or it
could be that we don't it could be that
we have a mirror mere
approximation to deeper laws that will
be
revealed through experiment and
observation and research
over the next 10 20 100 000 10 000 years
i don't know how long it's going to take
but i have confidence that in whatever
laws
we come up with whatever laws our
future brethren come up with i do not
believe that fundamentally within the
laws there will be anything that we can
identify as karma
or luck or consciousness or good
or evil or wonder or love
or surprise or anxiety or any of the
qualities that are vital
to understanding ourselves as human
beings
navigating the reality that
we are within rather these higher level
concepts
are manufactured by the human brain or
other brains
may manufacture them too or other ideas
may come from other brains but the point
is
these concepts are manufactured
certainly by
human beings because they're useful
when human beings come together in
communities
and want to have an effective and
efficient way
of navigating the environment and
surviving
and so these ideas are powerful
they're useful but they are not
fundamental in the same way that
einstein's equations or schrodinger's
equations are fundamental they're just
different
josh bakshi asks are you vegan yes i am
vegan
i'll leave that at that follow up if
you'd like
strumento asks can we upload our brain
well certainly not today we cannot
upload our brains
obviously in many sci-fi scenarios
people have imagined
that you might be able to upload your
brain and i don't see any fundamental
reason why we couldn't now look there's
a big assumption in there i'm assuming
that our brains and our thoughts and our
consciousness and our sense of self
our personal ability to conjure
inner worlds of self-reflective
experience i believe that all of that is
nothing but the motion of particles
coursing through a particular structure
that is the template within which
those processes happen and the substrate
within which
those experiences take place not
everybody agrees with that right i mean
there are some who suggest that
consciousness is out there
there's kind of like a consciousness
field that we tap into
i don't see any evidence for that can't
prove it wrong
but i do base my views
on reality on the things that we have
confirmed through observation and
experiment
and so focusing upon the things that
we've established with experiment
and observation it leads me to the
materialist
physicalist view that i just articulated
now if that's the case if the physical
stance is correct
then in order to upload my brain or
yours we just need to replicate
the physical structure and we need to
replicate the physical processes taking
place in that physical structure
so if you're able to do that then i
don't see any reason why the resulting
artificial manufactured structure would
not think
and feel exactly say as i do if it was
modeled upon my
brain at this particular moment and
similarly for your brain
can we do that no it's hard will we be
able to that one day
i don't see any fundamental obstacle but
whether we'll
gain the expertise to do that with
adequate fidelity to really reproduce
the brain that's inside your head in my
head right now i don't know
but fundamentally i don't think the laws
of physics as we understand them
stand in the way of that
[Music]
um so gulab asks what are time and space
and can strengthen your answer this at a
deeper level so i don't know if gulab if
you were with us in the first hour
where we uh had a conversation with
string theorist
cameron vapha and that was one of the
things that that we discussed
and as kumam was saying you know there
are a lot of insights
into the nature of space and time that
are coming from string theory
one of the most striking is one that
we're going to do a full
world science festival program on in the
in the coming weeks
has to do with quantum entanglement
which is the answer to
an earlier question on the
nature of bell's inequalities that that
i described before
but quantum entanglement suggests that
the threads
stitching the fabric of space may
actually be the threads of quantum
entanglement that in some sense connect
distant particles in the manner that i
described before
so that would suggest that
we are heading toward a deeper
understanding of space and time because
we are beginning to identify
the threads that stitch them but as
kumra and vaffa describe
descriptions of space and time in one
domain and one theoretical framework can
be distinct from and even contradict the
descriptions coming from
other corners of the illuminated
landscape of string theory
so it's not to say that we have an
answer
the answer for what space and time are
much as kerman said it may be that
the best we'll ever be able to do is say
in this in this circumstance according
to this and this
way of describing that circumstance
mathematically
here is how you should think about space
and time and then
in the same or subsequent breath we may
say but in this circumstance
according to this theoretical framework
using this mathematical articulation
this is the way you should talk about
space
and time and it may not be that one of
those is right
and the other is wrong i mean that both
are right it may be that both
are right and complementary and maybe
the fullest story
comes from this mosaic
this amalgam of distinct descriptions
and it's only by
taking in the full mosaic that will have
the deepest and fullest understanding
of what space and time are
okay i'm gonna head back here to uh your
youtube
questions so i know that a lot of you
are watching in different
different channels uh although i'm
focused right now on the world
science you youtube i probably should
have said that those of you who are
watching on the world
no no the world science festival youtube
it's very confusing isn't it
we have a lot of properties out there so
in the world science festival youtube
that's where i am right now ask any
questions that you want if you're on the
world science you youtube i'm not
looking at those i can't look at
multiple feeds
but maybe someone on our team will pick
out some questions there and add it to
my alternate feed coming from the social
channels
so it's up to you where you're looking
at this but uh
i am focusing on the world's high
special youtube feed and given that
what do we have here
okay
so daryl dawkins asks how is it possible
to express the age of the universe using
years since years refer to the earth
going around the sun
how are the years calculated before a
star even existed yeah
good question right so we talk about
three 13.8 billion years
what does that mean if you're talking
about a measure
that's tightly tied to the motion of the
earth around the sun
and the earth's only been going around
the sun for the last five billion years
so
what we do daryl is we use the duration
of year as defined by
the duration it takes right now in the
common era
for the earth to go on a full orbit
around the sun
we use that duration as our
fundamental scale of time
and then we use our mathematical
equations to work out
the duration back to the big bang and we
express that duration
in terms of how many times an
earth would have had to go around the
sun
at the speed that it currently does and
in that way we express the duration back
to the big bang in this particular unit
called the year we're not literally
imagining
that there were 13.8 billion orbits of
the earth around the sun
since the big bang because as you
rightly point out for instance at the
moment to the big bang the earth didn't
exist the sun didn't exist
rather we're being a little bit more
abstract than that we're imagining
the earth going around the sun is just
providing us a definition
of a standard duration called the year
and then relative to that standard
duration we calculate the time back to
the big bang
and calculate how many times the earth
would have had to go around the sun
to exhaust the duration back to the big
bang and that's where the 13.8 billion
years
comes from and you know there's a
related question to that which is you
know we learned from special relativity
that time varies depending upon your
motion and the general theory of
relativity we learned that time varies
depending upon the gravitational field
that you are
experiencing so when we talk about 13.8
billion years
what do we really mean by that which
clock are we using are we using a clock
that is in motion and therefore we
differ from other clocks and so on
and the answer is going back to the
question before
we imagine that the universe is
homogeneous and isotropic which means
that
it looks the same in more or less every
direction if you average things out
and every chunk of the universe that's
sufficiently large
on average looks like every chunk of the
universe
and because of that uniformity we
imagine that we have clocks that are
experiencing that
average motion of expansion
that average gravitational influence of
the things in the environment
and because the averages are the same
everywhere every clock is experiencing
the same relativistic effects and
therefore every clock
is taking off time at the same rate so
using those universal clocks
that are experiencing the average
density in the average expansion motion
of space
we are calculating that the duration
back to the big bang would be 13.8
billion years that's what we mean
by that all right few more what time is
it now we've been going about two and a
half hours so i'm gonna probably wrap
this up
relatively soon as i'm i am
starving and thanks for coming at this
different time by the way so
as i mentioned last time that we met i
have to teach
at our old time of 2 p.m eastern
standard time
so this will be our new time going
forward i think uh who knows maybe we'll
move it around and get people in
different time zones i don't know if
that'll be more confusing than it's
worth but we'll see
so um a few more questions though
uh arnov asks where do you teach i teach
at columbia university
columbia university in manhattan and it
was just announced that columbia
university is going to be
fully online for the undergraduate
education so i will be teaching fully
online
so in principle yeah no matter where you
are you can take my classes
i don't think it works that way though
if colombia gave every class away like
that
they might have i don't know trouble
attracting students
to pay tuition especially if
students are not coming to campus wow
difficult interesting questions that
people need to deal with in this
era but yes i do teach at columbia
university and i'm actually teaching a
course i'm not teaching a technical
course so maybe you guys wouldn't even
be interested
i am teaching a course on my new book
on the book until the end of time and i
do take the students right from the
beginning
of time to the end of time and there's a
bright spotlight that we shine
on the emergence of life the emergence
of mind
and that spotlight continues to
illuminate what
conscious minds do they develop language
they tell stories
they develop myths they develop
religions they engage in
artistic and creative expression and
they develop science to try to be able
to tell
the most accurate story of the objective
physical reality that allows for
all of these life like
activities to take place so that's what
the course is about sort of a blending
of science in the humanities
and um yeah maybe you guys if you're
interested some of you can audit that
course i don't know how that works so i
can't promise that but
uh sure that's what i'll be teaching
starting uh in a week or two
all right what do we have here
time traveler asks who first came up
with the idea of string theory and how
uh the very initial ideas of string
theory i think
are usually credited to the work of
a a very nice physicist friend of mine
known him for decades gabrielle
veneziano
and as the story goes gabrielle
benesiano was trying to understand
experimental data in the 1970s or even
1960s i'm sorry
yeah having to do with a strong nuclear
force
and noticed a pattern in the data of the
interactions of strongly interacting
particles
that could be described by a particular
interesting formula that he wrote down
and others i guess may have written down
too
and when other physicists began to study
this formula
that was very good at describing the
data of the strong nuclear reactions
they studied this formula and this is
people like
leonard suskind and people like i think
holger nielsen
and and others at the time they began to
see that in the mathematical description
of the nuclear force
you could see vibrating filaments in the
mathematics
or the qualities of vibrating filaments
were
embedded in the mathematical description
and this began to lead people to think
about
a theory based on strings and it's
interesting because
the data that gabrielle vanessana was
trying to describe was subsequent
subsequently and i was wrong with my
speech at the moment i guess two and a
half hours in i began to get dry mouth
so
hang on half a second here
the data that's better the data that
gabrielle veneziano
was looking at was subsequently
described
by a completely different theory the
theory of quantum chromodynamics
so the motivation for the formula that
beneziana wrote down
was undercut by these subsequent
developments in quantum chromodynamics
but nevertheless the formula had already
been written down
and the conclusion that that formula
described vibrating strings had already
been
met or made is perhaps a better word
and so string theory carried on even
after the motivation to describe the
nuclear reactions evaporated and that
mathematical endeavor ultimately
revealed a vibrating string
that had the properties of the graviton
the hypothetical graviton you could see
that right
inside the vibrating filaments which
themselves were right inside the formula
that veneziana wrote down and with that
people started to think wait
if you got a graviton this must be a
theory not of just the nuclear force but
of the gravitational force
and that's where the development of
string theory as a quantum theory of
gravity
really took off excuse me
okay a few more questions and then we
will
call it quits for today so anas
asks does the romanesian summation
have real life implications and
and i guess it depends on what you mean
by real life
but a lot of the insights of ramanujan
have had a role say in string theory
string theory of real life i don't know
but certainly the idea of the number of
dimensions
in string theory the
the ideas associated with
certain mathematical formulations make
use of
modular forms whose properties go back
to insights of
romanesians so i would say that a good
deal of the
mathematical framework of string theory
has an intellectual root that
trellis is back it's probably the wrong
verb there intellectual root that kind
of
digs its way back to the insights of
of ramanujans that's a very interesting
and exciting link between
abstract mathematical ideas and those of
cutting-edge physics
okay um
[Music]
uh
abhishek asks can more than two black
holes merge to form a single black hole
absolutely so if you have a collection
of black holes that that
come together ultimately as they
when they come together they will shake
the fabric of space
but as those merging black holes
ring down as the fabric of space carries
away enough energy from that collision
they will coalesce into a single big
black hole so yes although we often
describe the merger
as a binary operation between two black
holes
in principle it doesn't need to be that
it could be sequential right
two black holes come together yield one
and then a third black hole
joins with those to create an even
larger black hole or
it's unlikely but it's conceivable for
three black holes to just
come together in principle there's
nothing that would prevent that
from happening lahanash
asks can quantum entanglement be used to
transfer information faster than the
speed of light
and i think most of us believe that the
answer to that question is no
and i understand exactly where that
question is coming from
because as i described before if you
have these two distant entangled
particles
that are kind of in this state
of entanglement where
say one is up and one is down you
measure one the other
pops out and spins down that according
to the math of quantum mechanics is an
instantaneous process so you measure the
particle
in new york you find it up at the same
moment the particle in california spins
down it feels like there is
an instantaneous transfer of information
but actually there's no information to
be extracted whatsoever and the reason
is because look in new york let's say
you do this experiment over and over and
over again
and you look at your data what would
your data be well you go and you measure
the electron in new york
spinning up on the first run and then
you measure it and
spinning down on the second one and you
measure in the thermal spinning down on
the third one and spinning up on the
fourth one
so you have a random sequence of ups and
downs and ups and downs in new york
if you look at the data in california it
will also be a random sequence of ups
and downs but the
only interesting fact being that when
this one in new york is up
this one in california is down when this
one in new york is down this one in
california is up
now that's an interesting correlation
between the data but you can only
recognize that correlation when you
bring the two data sets together
you get on the phone you talk to the
person at the distant location you say
hey my data was
up up down down what was your data they
say hey mine was
down down up up you're like whoa
complete correlation
when yours is up mines down and vice
versa or you could take your data set
and you got an airplane you fly to the
other side of the country and you can
pay your data set
in person my point though is you have to
do that comparison
in order for you to extract anything
informationally
interesting about the data but that
comparison
is through an ordinary classical slower
than light
channel so the only time you extract
anything informationally interesting
about these two data sets is through
that slower than light
comparison and that's why there's no
faster than light information that's
being transferred or can be extracted
from quantum entanglement
okay i think guys i'm gonna
wrap it up today i uh
am still getting my
[Music]
my ability to go three full hours back
into shape right i have to sort of
exercise more to do that
so thanks for joining us today and
i i don't know when our next session is
it's either next friday or the friday
after
sort of play it by year some of these
times we'll have a guest
as we did today and many of you thought
that was interesting last time and let
me know if you thought it was
interesting and useful today i i had a
good time
speaking with karma bath carmen bath
about his book
and uh next time we'll venture forth
into again whatever directions you'd
like to go i
i love to hear from you guys through
social media again i'm
b green at on on twitter i'm b green at
facebook i think i'm b green too but i
haven't used it in a while so
i have to figure that out you should
subscribe i don't know where the
subscribe button is
it's like somewhere at the bottom of the
screens here i'm not going to try to use
oh is there a subscribe button i don't
know i hope there's a subscribe button
down there but uh if there is a
subscribe button do join him
because then you'll be alerted when
these sessions and other programs are
happening
and uh yeah keep keep abreast of what
we're doing
we're going to have some new courses
coming out in world science u
we're going to talk to many of the
faculty on world sciences whose courses
we will be releasing
and i'm always here to answer any of the
questions that come to your mind be they
in quantum mechanics cosmology
general relativity basic physics string
theory
as you see i'm happy to talk about
certain aspects of philosophy religion
consciousness mind brain if you find
what i say interesting fantastic if you
don't that's fantastic too
but i hope that you do and uh until next
time then
uh keep your interest going keep the
questions coming and i look forward to
uh
having our conversation either next week
or
the week after until then take care
you